RESOURCES AND WATER WILL COME
TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT
PUBLIC. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATOR STERN SENATE
STERN IF YOU HAVE A STAFF
PERSON WITH YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
AYE TO FIVE THAT STAT PERSON
NOW. SENATOR RESEARCH MIGHT
TAKE OFF MY DID DIRECTOR JEREMY
WILL. THANK AND GOOD MORNING.
MORNING SENATOR TURN IT THE
REMOTES PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE
SIR COMPUTER THIS WILL GREATLY
AID IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I S. THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THE
EASE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO UN MUTE PLEASE SELECT AN
MEET BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING.
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZE SPEECH PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY DRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TWO OTHER ACCESS
WITH MA'AM OF THE- TO HEAR ROOM.
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS NINE SIX THREE EIGHT.
TWO THREE SIX. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR THE COMMITTEES WEST. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN. ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. CHRIS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LOT NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE I NEEDED.
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER PRESS TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING.
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THIS HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO-
INTERESTING SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. MEMBERS
SYMPATHETIC TODAY WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
SEVEN BILLS ARM PROPOSED
CONSENT. THE BILL SOME PROPOSED
CONSENT OR AB EIGHT THREE EIGHT
AB TEN SEVENTY ONE. AB NINETEEN
FORTY NINE AB NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHT ZERO NINE
AB THREE ONE SIX FOUR AND A. B.
THIRTY TWO TWENTY SIX. MEMBERS
IN PUBLIC ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER HAS BEEN PULLED.
AGENDA ARE WE HERE PRESENT ON
BILLS I'D LIKE TO STEP A CALL.
AND ASK THE CONSULTANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MONNING
MONNING HERE MONNING- BY HERE
JONES JONES HERE ALLEN. FORGES
BORDERS HERE CABALLERO.
HERTZBERG HUESO HERE HUESO HERE
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE STERN
ARE THERE. SENATOR WHEATON
COULD YOU REPEAT THAT PLEASE.
I'M HERE STERN HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU A QUORUM
HAVING BEEN ESTABLISHED IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. I HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSULTANT WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I JUST
READ THOSE ASSEMBLY BILL ITEMS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
MONNING. HI MONNING HI JONES HI
JONES HI ALAN. FOR HI GORGEOUS
I COMEY. HEARD HUESO WESSEL
WHERE ALL RIGHT JACKSON JACKSON
I'D JACKSON HIS. STERN AYE
STERN HI. THAT HAS SIX VOTES
WILL IT ON BECAUSE- HE THEN HAS
SIX ROAD ON THE CAN CAL IT
REMAIN ON WE WILL NOW TURN TO
OUR FIRST AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI PRESENTING ON
AB THREE FORTY FIVE AND JUST
BEFORE YOU TAKE OVER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WERE INFORMED WE HAVE
OVER THREE HUNDRED ON THE LINE
WAITING TO TESTIFY SO WE WILL
PROCEED AS TO OUR PROTOCOL AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE THOSE SINCE.
PRIOR TO MAKING SOME TESTIMONY.
OUR SU CHI IN PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. AB
THREE FORTY FIVE. THIS IS A TO
YOUR BILL THAT SEEKS TO ADDRESS
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. THAT
HAS EXISTED IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR FOR TOO LONG. THIS BILL
WILL PROTECT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OVER 90% FROM
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FROM THE
HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS OF OIL
DRILLING IN THE BACKYARDS WHERE
CHILDREN LIVE IN PLAY AND GO TO
SCHOOL AND WHERE THE SICK AND
ELDERLY RECEIVE MEDICAL CARE.
THIS BILL RURAL PART THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
TO CREATE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM WITHIN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. AND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY NEAR OIL AND
GAS EXTRACTION ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING A REGULATION TO
ESTABLISH MINIMUM SETBACKS
BETWEEN OIL AND ACTION
ACTIVITIES. AND HOMES SCHOOLS
PLAYGROUNDS AND HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. STUDY AFTER STUDY
LINK THE PROXIMITY TO OIL AND
GAS WELLS THROUGH INCREASED
RISK OF ASTHMA AND OTHER
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES WHICH ARE
OF HEIGHTENED CONCERN DURING
THIS CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
OTHER HEALTH RISKS THIS
INCLUDES CANCER PRE TERM BIRTHS
AND HIGH RISK PREGNANCIES. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN PURSUANT TO S.
B. FOUR BY SENATOR PAVOLETTI
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY ISSUED A
REPORT RECOMMENDING THE MINIMUM
OIL DRILLING SETBACKS THAT THIS
BILL CALLS FOR. YET DESPITE
NUMEROUS STUDIES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS CALIFORNIA
STILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT OIL AND
GAS DRILLING NEAR SENSITIVE
LAND USES LIKE HOMES SCHOOLS
AND HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
OTHER OIL PRODUCING STATES AS
WELL AS CITIES HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED MINIMUM OIL DRILLING
SETBACKS. COLORADO AND MARYLAND
HAVE ADOPTED A THOUSAND FOOT
MINIMUM SETBACK REQUIREMENTS.
PENNSYLVANIA WYOMING NORTH
DAKOTA LOUISIANA THEY HAVE
ADOPTED FIVE HUNDRED FOOT
SETBACKS. AND EVEN THE CITY OF
DALLAS IN THE STATE OF TEXAS
HAS ADOPTED A FIFTEEN HUNDRED
FOOT OIL DRILLING SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ADOPT AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PROGRAM INCLUDING A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BUFFER ZONE
TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY WHERE 90%
OF NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING HAS
TAKEN PLACE N. BROWN AND BLACK
COMMUNITIES. NOW I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF JOBS.
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THIS BILL
WITH THREATEN GOOD UNION JOBS
IN THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL WANT
YOU TO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND GOOD UNION JOBS.
THIS IS A FALSE CHOICE. WE CAN
HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
GOOD JOB. FIRST I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT THIS BILL IS
COSPONSORED BY ASKED ME YOU D.
W. AND SUPPORTED BY SEIU
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY. IN
THEIR LETTER OF SUPPORT ASKED
ME YOU W. STATES FOR FAR TOO
LONG WORKERS AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BORNE
THE BRUNT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
RACISM AND CLIMATE CHANGE. AB
THREE FORTY FIVE IS A BILL THAT
PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF WORERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHO ARE CONTINUOUSLY EXPOSED TO
FOSSIL FUEL POLLUTION. ON AND
THEN OFF THE JOB. SECOND THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ABOUT JOB
LOSSES ARE BASED ON A PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THIS BILL WHICH
MANDATED A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
FOOT SETBACK. WE SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED THIS BILL FROM LAST.
AFTER THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCES
PLAN TO INITIATE A RULEMAKING
PROCESS TO UPDATE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS FOR
COMMUNITIES NEAR OIL AND GAS
DRILLING OPERATIONS. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO PROVIDE LEGISLATIVE
GUIDANCE TO SPECIFICALLY CALL
FOR AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDES OIL
DRILLING SETBACKS. BUT AGAIN
LET ME MAKE IT CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FOOT SETBACK OR A SET
BACK OF ANY SPECIFIED DISTANCE.
INSTEAD OF THIS BILL DIFFERS
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT ITS
MAKING IT ELSE. THANK AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT AND ALL ON HOW
TO SET. WELL PRESERVING OR A
FOR. NEW JOBS. AND SOME THIS
BILL IS ABOUT A BAR JUSTICE.
AND WE CANNOT FIGHT SYSTEMIC
RACISM WITHOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WE CAN HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND GOOD
JOBS. I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
WORK ON THIS BILL. I AM PLEASED
TO BE JOINED IN THE GALLERY. BY
KATE WITH THE VALENZUELA THE
POLICY AND POLITICAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
AS WELL AS RUBEN RODRIGUEZ A
RESIDENT OF COALINGA AND A
FORMER OIL INDUSTRY MECHANIC
WILL BE TESTIFYING OVER THE
PHONE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AN ON
THE RECORD FOR ACCEPTING THOSE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS JUST
BEFORE WE MOVED TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- LET ME REMIND YOU THAT
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS.
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE
WILL BE PER IN AMOUNT OF TIME.
AS I DID. IN TODAY THAT WILL BE
FOUR MINUTES ON EACH SIDE SO
THE FIRST TESTIMONY BROUGHT BY
THE AUTHOR IN SUPPORT CAN
DIVIDE FOUR MINUTES AMONG THE
TWO. AND THEN WHEN WE AND THEN
THAT'LL BE FOLLOWED BY THE
TELEPHONIC OR PEOPLE THAT MAY
BE PRESENT ADD ON NAME.
FILIATION AND ENDED YOUR SOME.
FOR YOUR OPPOSITION FOR THE
BILL THERE WILL BE NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY AFTER THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES HAVE IS TO THEIR
MINUTES. AND JUST BEFORE WE
MOVED TO THE WITNESSES LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION HAS NO
POSITION ON AB FORTY FIVE. THEY
WERE MISTAKENLY LISTED IN
SUPPORT ON THE ANALYSIS AND
HAVE NO POSITION SO PLEASE
CORRECT YOUR COMMITTEE AND
ANALYSIS ACCORDINGLY AND NOW WE
WILL GO TO THE GALLERY FOR THE
TESTIMONY OF KATIE VALENZUELA.
AGAIN A TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES
FOR- AFFIRMATIVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. MISSPELLING SAILOR
WELCOME. THANK YOU CHAIR MATH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE AT OVER ONE
HUNDRED GROUPS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FOUR FIVE BUT I'M ALSO
HERE TODAY AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN OIL DOWN
KERN COUNTY AND I'M PROUD OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PUSH. THAT
SENT ME DR. IN THE HOUSE. MORE
TIME THAN I CAN COUNT. AND THAT
IS CURRENTLY MAKING THE
FIGHTING CARBON NINETEEN AND MY-
MORE DIFFICULT. FOR MY MOM
WHO'S SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND
KERN COUNTY AND HAS IT RIGHT
NOW AND FOR MY SISTER WHO IS A
FRONTLINE WORKER IN BAKER'S
LARGEST HOSPITAL. TO PUT THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE LIKE MY FAMILY
AHEAD OF ANY ECONOMIC PROFIT.
SO WHILE YOU'RE LISTENING TO
TESTIMONY TODAY I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO REMEMBER THREE THINGS.
FIRST THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE ONLY OIL PRODUCING STATES
BUT DOES NOT HAVE A STEP BACK
AND POLICY. SECOND THAT THE
ONLY. THE VOIGTS IS A RESIDENT
AND ACADEMIC EXPERTS WHO ARE
TELLING US THAT THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS ARE NOT ENOUGH TO
PROTECT HEALTH. AND THIRD I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO REMEMBER DON
MARTIN. FATHER AND GRANDFATHER
WHO LIVED IN LOS ANGELES THREE
HUNDRED FEET AWAY FROM AN OIL
WELL AND JUST MORE LOSS OF HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY YEARS TO CANCER.
HE JUST WROTE AN OP ED WITH
JANE FONDA AND THE- BE
IMPLORING YOU TO TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT HIS FAMILY. I WOULD ASK
YOU TO THINK TO YOURSELF WHAT
YOU WILL TELL DONMAR IF WE DO
NOT TAKE ACTION TODAY AND ALL
THE FOR A OF MY TIME TO READ
AND- THANK YOU WE WILL. RIGHT
READ COLIN HE WILL COME IN ON
OUR LINE MODERATOR. INTRODUCE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU GET YOUR WEEK YES
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS OBERNOLTE
GET I'M AIR QUALITY MONITOR
TECHNICIAN FOR THE DEFENSE OF
IN THE AGRICULTURE CITY OF YOUR
LONG. A FORMER EMPLOYEE THE
PETROLEUM INDUSTRY ANY RESIDENT
OF TO THE LAND OF THE UNITED
YOU'LL- I WOULD TO SPEAK TODAY
HONOR OF THE WATER THIS AND THE
LAND THAT IS DIRECTLY BEING
COULD. WE ARE WORKERS. WORK E
CENTRAL TO. THAT ARE SOME OF
MOST. WHEN YOU'RE TO COME
SOURCE IF. THE IN. THAT COME
FROM ALL OPERATE. EVEN WORSE
TODAY DURING THE STANDING.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. THEIR LIFE
WITHOUT BENEFIT OF THE STATE.
AND PREVENTATIVE RESOURCE. MANY
OF YOU ARE PRIVILEGE TO HAVE.
WON SOME DOES NOT DO WE- JOB IN
THIS. WORK THE OUTCOMES BE DEAD.
NOT ONLY TO WORK. WITH CLEANING
AROUND THE AREA ALSO GIVEN BY
OUR. EIGHTY THREE POINT FIVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND WE WILL START IN
THE GALLERY IF THERE ARE ANY.
MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE
IN AND REMIND YOU ITS NAME
AFFILIATION. AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THIS IS THE TIME
FOR SUPPORTERS I THINK WE DO
HAVE I SEE A WITNESS IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR INTRODUCTION. HI MY NAME
IS INGRID BROSTROM A WITH THE
CENTER ON RACE POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT REGISTERED SUPPORT
FOR THE- I ALSO HAVE SUPPORT
FROM CATHOLIC CHARITIES DIOCESE
OF STOCKTON. CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NETWORK
THREE FIFTY SOUTH BAY LOS
ANGELES INDIVISIBLE SOUTH BAY
LOS ANGELES PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE. AND
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND THE OTHERS WHO
WISH TO ADD THEIR SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE WE
WILL CHECK IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ANY WITNESS IN TWENTY FORTY WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY. SEEING NO
RESPONSE WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES AND MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY
FIVE WE WILL BEGIN AND I WILL
JUST REMIND TO THOSE WAITING IN
THE YOU ON THE PHONE. YOU
PROVIDE YOUR NAME ANY
ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION AND
SIMPLY STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL THERE BE NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY THAN THAT OF
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES INDIVIDUALLY. CAN
THANK YOU YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE ALREADY
IN Q. NOT PRESS THE ONE AND
GENERAL AGAIN OR YOU WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THE QUEUE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SUPPORT OF AB THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THIS TIME. REPORT
WILL BE. MINE FIVE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIVE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
PLEASE PROCEED. ON MUTE IF
YOU'RE A MUTED. NO RESPONSE
FIVE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN BONTA
LINE. ONE ZERO FIVE NINE ONE OH
FIVE. NINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME NINE ONE ZERO
YES NOW WE CAN THANK YOU IF YOU-COULD JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
IF AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I
THINK YOUR CUES MESSED UP BY
MEN FOR MEN- OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY THIRTY. THAT'S NOT THE
BILL THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
HEARING- THOSE IN THE QUEUE NOW
SHOULD BE TO TESTIFY. THIS IS
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON AB THREE
FORTY FIVE BYE MURATSUCHI LET
ME REMIND PEOPLE WHO ARE
LISTENING ON YOUR PHONE. LISTEN
ON YOUR PHONE LINE NOT THE TV
OR COMPUTER THERE CAN BE A
DELAY SO TO HEAR THE PROMPT
FROM THE MODERATOR PLEASE STAY
ON YOUR PHONE LINE. AND THEN
RESPOND WHEN YOU ARE INTRODUCED
FOR YOUR COMMENT THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LINE FOR
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NEAR THE IS YOUR FROM THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB. CONCORD BUILDING HERE.
NINE FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YOUR MEMBERS CALTRAIN
ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA AND FORT. NINE SIX
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KATHY ARE ABOUT HALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NINE SIX THIRTY TWO.
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WITH YOUR LIFE
THIS IS MARGIE LEWIS FROM
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY THREE FOUR FIVE.
NINE FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
VICTORIA WRONG WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE S. CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS SON RIGHT BAY AREA.
CALIFORNIA RELIGIOUS ACTION
CENTER OF REFORM JUDAISM AND
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS LAUREN FONG
WITH SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
FORTY FIVE. NINE SIX ELEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JAY FROM
SEIU CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY
AS SHE WAS LISTED AS A
SUPPORTER ON THE BILL OUR
POSITION IS CURRENTLY NEUTRAL
THANK YOU. SO NOTED SEIU IS
NEUTRAL. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JURíDICAMENTE AND I AM
SECTION DID YOU AND- SENATOR
BEN HUESO I AM REPRESENTING TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF SAN DIEGO
THREE FIFTY AND WE SUPPORT YES
AND EIGHTY. FOUR HI. NINE SIX
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. APOLOGIES IF YOU
ALREADY HEARD ME THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION ON THE LINE THIS IS
JENNIFER LAURIE FROM WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. NINE TWO NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
TO NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I'M SHAUNA HONOR I
WORK FOR ERROR ENERGY AND- IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY FIVE.
NINE SIX OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
THIS IS DAN JACOBSON THE
DIRECTOR OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE FOUR SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR SEVENTY YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING THAT THE PHYSICAL
L. ENERGY HELLO IN THE THREE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. OKAY WE
ARE HEARING THOSE OPPOSITION
CALLS I WOULD ASK THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. TO WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION SO THAT
YOU CAN BE GROUPED BUT WE DID
HEAR THAT AND IT IS DULY NOTED
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE- SUPPORT. FIVE
YOUR LINE IS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS HELPING THEM
AND NOT THAT RESIDENTS CONTRA
COSTA COUNTYCITY OF BRENTWOOD
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL. NINE
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE NINE FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN. GABAY ON BEHALF OF-
SUGGESTED A LITTLE LATINO
OUTDOORS AUDUBON CALIFORNIA
REALLY MAJOR CONSERVANCY AND
SUPPORT. NINE FIVE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHANNELPOINT INTERFACE
CLIMATE ACTION NETWORK OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE.
ONE FOUR FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES WE
WILL GREATER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
NUMBERS OF THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO. AND ALSO CREATE.
NINE SIX TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KEVIN STEVENS ON THE
FRONT LINE RESIDENT IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE SIX TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE CALLING AS
A MEMBER- SIERRA CLUB LOS
ANGELES A PROUD SUPPORTER OF
STAND LA FOOD AND WATER WATCH
FOOD AND WATER ACTION SUPPORTER
OF COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER AND
BY OUR ENVIRONMENT. I HIGHLY
SUPPORT AB THREE FOUR FIVE AND
STOP WIMPING OUT ON TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED. MOVE ON A LOT OF
WRITER NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT
OF THREE OTHERS WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK PEOPLE TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES BY NAME ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR SUPPORT OR LATER
THEIR OPPOSITION IF YOU START
TRYING TO TESTIFY YOU TAKE TIME
AWAY. THE ABILITY OF OTHERS TO
PARTICIPATE LET'S KEEP THIS
HEARING OPEN FOR ALL TO
PARTICIPATE THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NINE THREE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS BRAD GARRETT
I'M WITH THE SANTA CRUZ CLIMATE
ACTION NETWORK AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE SOVIET KEY FROM ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK
AND STRONG SUPPORT. AND MY
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NINETY
SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE. TWO THIRTEEN NINE TO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELP WITH THAT
WE'RE- OUT ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO HEAR YOU
JUST ONE MOMENT. PLEASE TRY
AGAIN. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. IF
YOU CAN SPEAK JUST A LITTLE BIT
LOUDER OR MOVE YOUR MICROPHONE
AND YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW.
THAT WE CAN THANK YOU GO AHEAD
THANK YOU- ALFRED STATLER I AM
A CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR BEN
ALLEN AND WORK FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS WITHIN TWO HUNDRED
FEET OF THE DOUBLE. PLAY ONLY
SUPPORT. NINE TO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
TO SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVING ON TO. BE ON A LEASH AND.
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
ALSO BE ON MUTE. NINE THREE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY. NINE ONE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINE FOUR
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO
AHEAD. MY INTERNET OR WANT TO
HEAR ME. NOW WE CAN GO AHEAD.
ATLANTIC AMERICA'S. AIR ENERGY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
REPORTING BY. AND LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROSTRON YEAR-
REPRESENTING CENTER RESOURCES
COMPANY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY THREE FORTY FIVE. TEN
NINE SIX SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS EDWIN LINDO WE'RE
COMPLETE SIXTY SIX AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. THREE
TWENTY FIVE. THE WORKERS. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
FORTY FIVE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. THREE FORTY
FIVE AND YOU ARE IN THE COMMON
Q. CURRENTLY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
NINE THREE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AGAIN THE COUPON BOX
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS REPRESENTING OUR-
WELL. ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BUILDING GREG MEMBERS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
RIGHT IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT IS RECORDED BUT
AGAIN A REMINDER IS THE
MODERATOR JUST SUGGESTED THIS
IS THE QUEUE FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU'RE IN THE QUEUE.
TO OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW AND THEN RE JOIN US
WHEN WE GET TO THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES THANK YOU MODERATOR
PLEASE PROCEED. NINE SEVEN
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD
BUT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU THIS IS WHAT
D. HASTINGS WITH THE CLIMATE
CENTRE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE SIX FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE. IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND LINE SIX FORTY FOUR YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MADELEINE ROSE FROM
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS A BALLOT DROP HOLE WITH
CALIFORNIA INTERFAITH POWER AND
LIGHT WATER CLEAN AIR AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND STAND LA.
ALONG WITH SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. AT
NINE SIX NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FOUR FIVE
THANK YOU. IN LINE SEVEN TWENTY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS BARBARA
FASSLER I'M A REGISTERED NURSE
WITH THE ALLIANCE THE NURSES
FOR A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AT NINE TO FORTY
FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TO FORTY FOUR
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND MOVING ON TO LINE.
SIX NINETY SEVEN NINETY SIX
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M CALLING
FROM. I'M SORRY YOUR PHONE CUT
OUT AGAIN PLEASE. NINE SIX
NINETY SEVEN YOUR PHONE CUT OUT
OR YOU'RE ON MUTE. HI I'M
CHRISTINE BOSC HAMEL I
REPRESENT UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS THANK YU W. ASKED ME
REPRESENT WORKERS WHO LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY THE BILL WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. N. NINE
ONE SIXTY TWO. NINE ONE SIX
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DOUG ROGERS WERE PRESENTED TO
RESOURCES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB THREE FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. TO REMIND CALLERS
FOR TAKING CALLING CHECK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS POINT MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
NINE ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JOHN LAWSON WAS
CYNICAL RESOURCES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE CALLING IN SUPPORT.
OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE. AND
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE FORTY FIVE YOU WILL HAVE
A CHANCE SHORTLY TO SPEAK YOUR
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE IN THE
COMMENT Q. S. ONE AND THEN ZERO
TO LEAVE A COMMENT UEUE AT
THIS TIME. FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB B.
THREE FORTY FIVE. AN OPERATOR
WILL TAKE YOUR AND GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER SHORTLY TO YOU. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE
AND IN THE QUEUE AND OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU YOUR LINE
NUMBER IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION AND ARE IN THE
COMMENT Q. S. ONE IN THIS. AND
ZERO TO LEAD THE COMIC YOU AT
THIS TIME. THIRTY NINE SEVEN
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AGREE
THAT HELLO MY NAME THE NETWORK
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE BRITNEY ACTION
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY PEOPLE IF I. NINE SIX
FORTY BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE SIX FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY I'M
NOT OPPOSED OKAY THE CAR WHEN
WE GET T THE OPPOSITION TO
STYLE ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE SEVEN
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND MOVING ON ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE SIX EIGHTY SIX
POINT SIX EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIX EIGHTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON IT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MOVING ON
TO LINE SIX FIFTY EIGHT LINE
SIX FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY
SIX FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY AND
LIVING ON. MIAMI HUNDRED SEVEN
TWELVE POINT SEVEN TWELVE
THIRTY SECONDS A CALL ONE
MOMENT UNITS MOVING ON IN WENT
FROM TWENTY NINE SEVEN TWELVE
DESIGNERS OF SIMPLY GO AHEAD
JUST JUMPED UP TO TWENTY SEVEN.
TWENTY SEVEN LISTEN SUPPORT
OKAY I'M SORRY COULD YOU REPEAT.
YOUR NAME AND ADDRESS PLEASE.
YOU GET DOWN AND- THIS IS NOT A
ROVING CHARACTER LBA ALASKAN
BUSINESS OFFICE OPPOSES. THANK
YOU OF THOSE WHO ARE CALLING IN
IN OPPOSITION WE ARE RECORDING
THAT YOU ARE BEING HEARD. BUT
THE BEST WAYS TO DO IT WITH
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SO RIGHT
NOW WE ARE INVITING THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY FIVE.
NAME AFFILIATION. IN YOUR
SUPPORT IF YOU'RE IN THE LINE
TO OPPOSE. PLEASE DIAL ONE ZERO
NOW IT'LL TAKE YOU OUT OF THE
SUPPORT LINE AND WHEN WE START
OPPOSITION YOU CAN EAD JOIN IN
THE OPPOSITION LINE THANK YOU
MODERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. FOUR
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS
FOUR ZERO ONE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
MOVING ON. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SOME OF. CIRCULATE
BUTTON LINE FOR SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND LIVING ON.
RIGHT. YEAH YOUR. OKAY. NINETY
SEVEN FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES GO AHEAD FINALLY
CLEAR ONE SEVEN FOURTEEN LIGHT
A LITTLE BIT BETTER. GET YOU
COULD START. YOU CAN BUY FALL
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY MODERATOR AND
MEMBERS WE THINK WE HAVE A LOT
IN THE QUEUE WERE ACTUALLY IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION THERE
MAY STILL BE SOME WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME- WE WILL MOVE
TO THE- OPPOSITION THE LIVE
OPPOSITION THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES NOW WILL GO BACK TO
THE PHONES FOR. ONAN TO LINE
UP. AND THEN WE WILL AT THE END
OF THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IF
WE IDENTIFY OTHERS WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN HEARD IN SUPPORT WE WILL
GIVE YOU THAT OPPORTUNITY. SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK INTO
THE GALLERY WE HAVE THREE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THEY WILL
BE SHARING FOUR MINUTES DIVIDED
AMONG THEM HOWEVER THEY WANT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS. THEY ARE
IN THE SENATE GALLERY AND- WE
WILL PROCEED. E. L<c.cyan>G GARCIA</c>
THE FIRST WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THREE FORTY FIVE AND WE
WILL START THE TIMER WHEN YOU
START YOUR TESTIMONY WELCOME.
CAN WE GET THE MICROPHONE IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE. LET'S TRY
THAT AGAIN WHEN INTRODUCED
YOURSELF. PLEASE SPEAK RIGHT
INTO THE MICROPHONE- THERE WE
GO. THAT PHONE START WILL NOT
BE USED AGAINST TIME LET'S
START NOW ALL RIGHT WE'LL START
A NEW THERE YOU GO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU AYE GARCIA
FOR THE WESTERN STATE PATROL
SAYS HE- PREVENTING THE STATE.
REFINERS A TRANSFER FUELS VERY
MUCH IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT NOT ONLY PROVIDES
DIRECTION TO THE REGULATORS IN
THE CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY RULE MAKING IT PRETTY
DETERMINES THE OUTCOME. IT
FORCES AN ARBITRARY. AND
STATEWIDE SET BACK. WORK
WITHOUT INFORMATION WITHOUT
DATA AND WITHOUT THE SIGNS
THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
STUDIES AND SCIENCE THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING CONSIDERED
IN THE RULEMAKING AND IT SHOULD
BE PLAYED OUT. A STATEWIDE STEP
BACK RESULT WILL RESULT IN LOST
JOBS IT WILL RESULT. IN MORE
DEPENDENT ON OUT OF STATE
ENERGY SOURCES. OUR INDUSTRY IS
FULLY COMMITTED TO
PARTICIPATING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY RULE MAKING. WHERE
THERE HAS ALREADY BEEN FORTY
THOUSAND COMMENTS FILED IN I'LL
JUST NOTE THAT WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING HERE TODAY FOUR
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. FOR FORTY
THOUSAND COMMENTS HAVE BEEN
FILED. WE ARE COMMITTED TO THAT
PROCESS AND WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO ALLOW THAT PROCESS TO PLAY
OUT. I'LL BE BRIEF TO ALLOW
TIME FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LABOR SECTOR TO SPEAK. BUT I
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT A SET BACK.
IT'S A POSSIBILITY IN THE
RULEMAKING IF IT IS SUPPORTED
BY THE SCIENCE AND BY THE DATA.
IF IT IS NOT SUPPORTED BY THE
DATA IN OTHER UP. THIS BILL
PRECLUDES OPTION. FOR THAT
REASON WE OPPOSE THE BILL AND
WE ASK YOU TO A LOT OF RULE
MAKING TO PROCEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WITNESS PLEASE GUYS
LATCH MISTER YOU W. MISTER
CHAIRMAN SCOTT WHICH SHOULD BE
OUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS WHY
HEARING THIS. AB THREE FORTY
FIVE IS TOTALLY UNNECESSARY AND
TERRIBLY DESTRUCTIVE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH SETBACKS
AND MAYBE DO. MOREOVER THE
NEWSOME ADMINISTRATION IS MORE
THAN SIX MONTHS INTO A PROCESS
OF ESTABLISHING A NEW PUBLIC
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR OIL GAS.
AB THREE FORTY FIVE WILL HAVE
TO IMPACTS OF PAST MASSIVE JOB
LOSSES. IN THE STATE OCCURRING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN WHAT IS
A CLEAR UNCONSTITUTIONAL TAKING.
THIS WEEK ONE THOUSAND UNION
PLUMBERS PIPEFITTERS
ELECTRICIANS LOST THEIR JOBS AT
THE MARATHON REFINERY IN
MARTINEZ SINCE OPEC'S PRICE WAR
IN MARCH MY UNIONS HAVE LOST
FIVE THOUSAND MORE JOBS AND
BECAUSE OF KOBE NINETEEN MANY
OF MY LOCAL UNIONS HAVE MORE
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND UNEMPLOYED
30% UNEMPLOYMENT. HEALTH CARE
FOR THESE WORKERS IS BEGINNING
TO EXPIRE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
WELCH. I'M SORRY THAT SO I
WON'T COUNT THIS AGAINST YOUR
TIME WE DO HAVE THE DECORUM OF
THIS CHAMBER EVERYONE WEARS
MASKS EITHER ON TESTIFYING OKAY
PAUSE YOUR BACK ON. SINCE
OPEC'S PRICE WAR IN MARCH MY
UNIONS HAVE LOST MORE THAN FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS BECAUSE OF
COPIAGUE MANY OF MY LOCALS HAVE
30% UNEMPLOYMENT HEALTH CARE
FOR THESE WORKERS IS BEGINNING
TO EXPIRE. WAKE UP VISIT YOUR
LOCAL FOOD PANTRIES AND ASKED
THEM WHO THEY SEE ONLINE EVERY
DAY ASK YOURSELF IN LIGHT OF
ALL THIS IS THE BILL NECESSARY
IN THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC AND
IT ECONOMIC DEPRESSION. IF YOUR
ANSWER IS YES. PLEASE ALLOW ME
TO INVITE YOU TO A VIRTUAL TOWN
HALL. WITH MY UNEMPLOYED
MEMBERS SO THEY CAN SHARE WITH
YOU THE PLIGHT THAT THEIR
FAMILIES FACE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC I URGE YOU TO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WHICH WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOUR I UNDERSTAND- THE
THIRD WITNESS. IN OPPOSITION
JEREMY SMITH WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. ARE YOU WITH THIS IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE
PROCEED YOU HAVE ABOUT. FORTY
FIVE SECONDS THANK YOU SENATOR
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JEREMY
SMITH I'M HERE BEHALF OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION EIGHTY
THREE FORTY FIVE. THE BUILDING
TRADES THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY
PARTNERED UP SEVERAL YEARS AGO
TO ENSURE THAT THE MOST HIGHLY
SKILLED AND TRAINED
TRADESPEOPLE HELPED PRODUCE OIL
AND GAS AND CAL WE ARE THE
STRICTEST ENVIRONMENTAL AND
LABOR LAWS IN THE WORLD. THIS
PARTNERSHIP WAS ALLOWED THE
BUILDING TRADES APPRENTICE
PROGRAM TO GROW BY A FULL
TWENTY PERCENT. THIS MEANS
THERE ARE NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND MORE APPRENTICES BEING
TRAINED IN A TRADE THAT WILL
PROVIDE THEM WITH A PATH. CLASS
THIS IS WHAT THE TRADE. THERE
ARE VERY FEW PASS THE MIDDLE
FOR WHO ARE POWER BOUND THE
BUILDINGS IN THE AND GAS
INDUSTRY ARE TWO OF THE
REMAINING AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES
THIS PARTNERSHIP SO IMPORTANT
AND ALTHOUGH WE HAVE BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THE RENEWABLE
ENERGY SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
PROBABLY BUILDING THE TELLER
SCALE SOLAR AND WIND IN THE
STATE WE CANNOT STAND IDLE WHEN
THOUSANDS OF BLUE COLLAR JOBS.
BLUE COLLAR JOBS AND GAS
THREATENED BY RATHER THAN
SCIENCE. THIS BILL IF ENACTED
WILL COME WITH FOR BILLING
DOLLAR COST OF THE STATE TO ASK
YOU TO RAP ABOUT THE THINGS
YOUR OVERTIME. WORKING ALL
UNACCEPTABLE DURING THIS TIME
OF GREAT ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
FOR WORKING FAMILIES. AND
ACTING AB THREE FORTY FIVE WILL
DO NOTHING TO ALTER OUR
ENERGIES AND- TIME. IS EXPIRED
OR ABILITY TO PROVIDE JOBS FOR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WILL
MAKE HEALTH. AND INVESTED MORE
RELIANT OKAY I'LL ASK THE
MODERATOR TO IMPRISONMENT RULES
THAT MICROPHONE WE- FORTY DO
SOME EXTRA TIME. IN FAIRNESS TO
THOSE. WHO TESTIFIED MEDELLIN
SUPPORT. USED FOR MINUTES. YOU
FOR. AND SO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN A- WHO MIGHT
BE HERE IN THE GALLERY DO WE
HAVE ANY. WITNESSES NOW WHO
WILL ADD NAME. AFFILIATION IN
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
FORTY FIVE SING NINE IN THE
GALLERY. LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANY WITNESSES
THERE IN OPPOSITION I SEE A
COUPLE AGAIN- PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION. YOU MAY PROCEED
THURMOND. OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CRISTINA I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND ALSO THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS BOTH IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU'RE IN
THE QUEUE TOM. MODERATOR PLEASE
START TAKING CALLS NOW AND
AGAIN NAME. AFFILIATION IN THE
FACT THAT YOU OPPOSE IF ANYONE
GETS BROUGHT ON THE LINE WHO
DIDN'T GET HEARD IN SUPPORT
PLEASE AGAIN JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND
POSITION MODERATOR PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE QUEUE AND YOU
ARE IN FAVOR OF AB FOUR. FORTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
THIS TIME YOU WILL HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY. AFTER OPPOSITION.
EIGHTY THREE FORTY FIVE AND YOU
ARE IN THE COMMENT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. AND THEN ZERO TO
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE BE PATINT AS YOU
PROVIDED THE LINE NUMBER. AND
ANYONE WHO HAS NOT YET QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM. MINE.
THREE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
OPEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
IT'LL
BE JUST A BRIEF FONG.
FORMAL
RHINELANDER. ONE NINETY FOUR
ONE NINE FOUR PLEASE I HAD. MY
NAME IS PATRICK THANK I WILL I
WORK FOR ERROR ENERGY ON INCOME
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU OVER THE LINE
TO FORTY THREE POINT THREE.
STEVE YOUNG WAS SENATOR
RESOURCES AND I OPPOSE A. B.
REPORTER FIVE. THANK YOU A LOT
OF WIND. THREE THIRTY FOUR
THREE THREE FOUR. ALL. FIVE
THREE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CYNTHIA
HARGROVE. OF THEIR ENERGY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT AB THREE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHT
ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS TYSON RALPH AND I AM
AN EMPLOYEE OF THEIR ENERGY AND
AYE OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ONE. WHAT.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IT WILL BE
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT ROBERT.
BORDERLINE SIX THIRTY TO PLEASE
CALL AT. NAME ADDRESS. FIVE SIX
THREE TWO. RUSHING. TAKING
TESTIMONY HIGHLIGHTED XIN TO AB
THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU I'M
OF ADELINE ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SEAN HOLDSWORTH FROM HER ENERGY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU OVER THE
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JOSH WELL WHAT'LL WORK HER
ENERGY AYE OPPOSED AB THREE
FORTY FIVE. SHE THANK YOU WILL
PROVIDE A WIRE SIX NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MASON LOCALES
WITH ERROR ENERGY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU LINE THREE OH
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS CHRISTINE MORAN WITH AIR
ENERGY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THREE FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FONG LEE OPPOSE AB THREE
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE ONE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LEVINE THE LINE SEVEN ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT'S WRONG
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION WHERE AN
ONLINE COMPUTER BEEN
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT PART OF
MAKING OUTGOING PLAYERS THREE
AND A HALF MILLION EMPLOYED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB. THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU LINE FOR ALL.
ADD. THE NEW HOGAN GOES ON WITH
THEIR ENERGY AND THEIR COURSE
AB PRICKLY PART. THANK YOU I AM
SEVEN SIX SEVEN WE HAD. HI THIS
IS JOHN BOWEN I MEAN PLOY VERY
ENERGY. CLOSE TO AB THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU VITAL ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KILDARE'S MEN WITH SENATOR
RESOURCES COMPANY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION A BABY THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NINE FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
O'DONOGHUE EMPLOYEE AT ERA
ENERGY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M AN EMPLOYEE OF
THEIR ENERGY AD AYE OPPOSED AB
THREE TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
I'M- THREE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR WORK YEAH I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT THREE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH YOU ARE
YOU'RE A WHITE BOX. RIGHT A
LINE THREE TWENTY THREE GO
AHEAD. YEAH SO ENERGY I PULLED
A. B. THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
PAUL YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
RYAN EIGHT TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT EIGHT TWO TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL HOLD ON
THE LINE EIGHT TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS MAPPED OUT ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE TWO
OR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
MEN TO WIN EMPLOYEE OF THEIR
ENERGY STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
RYAN FOR TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DA COUNCILLORS SUPPORTED A
PRESS NOTE CAME STRONGLY
OPPOSED. I AM SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SEVEN ONE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY
NEIGHBOR OF THE CHEVRON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THREE FORTY
FIVE. WHY AM SIX FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE SIX FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I AM
THREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS KATHY BRENEMAN
WITH CHEVRON AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY THREE FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. BY FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND FOUR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MARIO COUNTRIES JOHN
WHICH DIVISION FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE FOUR
FIVE. THANK YOU AGAIN THIS IS
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION- I
KNOW SOME PEOPLE ARE WAITING
STILL TO VOICE SUPPORT WE WILL
COME BACK. TO GIVE PEOPLE IN
THE QUEUE WHO WANT TO SUPPORT
AN OPPORTUNITY. RIGHT NOW
OPPOSITION WE CURRENTLY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED IN
THE QUEUE AGAIN NAME. IS IT IN
PLEASE BE PREPARED WHEN THE
MODERATOR CALLS ON YOUR LINE
LISTEN ON YOUR TELEPHONE LINE
SO YOU DON'T FACE THE TIME GAP
IF YOU'RE WATCHING ON A
COMPUTER OR A LIVE STREAM
LISTEN TO YOUR PHONE BE
PREPARED WHEN YOUR LINES CALLED
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT THANK
YOU MODERATOR PROCEED. THANK
YOU LINE THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
SANDRA KESSLER I'M AN EMPLOYEE
WITH THEIR ENERGY AND I DO
OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIX
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS IS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE CAN WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN TWO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD AT. NINE
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
RESIDENCE TED KORD OF- I
REPRESENTING IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES WHICH IS BY SEVERAL
HUNDRED PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION AB THREE FOUR FIVE.
THANK YOU. BLIND TWO FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS KEN MILLER WITH
IRON WORKERS LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AND WE ARE CLOSED
AB THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE OH FIVE. I HAD. LINE
FIVE ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IAN HARRIS- ENERGY
OPPOSE BUILD THREE SIXTY FIVE
THREE FORTY FIVE PART. LINE TWO
OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WARD
CENTER STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
THREE FORTY FIVE. LINE THREE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING GREG BASHAM
TEAMSTERS AND NT A STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. BUT I NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE I HAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS IRVING BY YOUR GUY WITH
SENEGAL RESOURCES COMPANY LLC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. I AM SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS BARBARA CHEVRON
CORPORATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THREE FORTY FIVE. I
THANK FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE SEVEN FOUR SEVEN.
HI THIS IS BOB YOU KNOW WHAT
THE NICKEL RESOURCES. PRESIDENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THREE
FORTY BUT. BLIND FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY GO AHEAD. BY
KEVIN. I'M HUNDRED PLEASE CALL
ACT ADD. RIGHT ONE ZERO ZERO
THREE. JOHN BREAK CYNICAL
RESOURCES AYE OPPOSED AB THREE
FORTY FIVE. THE LION FOR
THIRTEEN PEOPLE HAD. I KNOW I
WORK IN THE OIL INDUSTRY IN L.
A. COUNTY MASTRANTONIO CLOSE
MAYBE THREE FOUR FIVE. SEVEN
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
I'M SEVEN ONE FOUR PLEASE CALL
US AT. RIGHT ONE NIGHT WHAT.
YES THIS IS KATHLEEN LONG WITH
ERIN AND I AB THREE CORE FIVE.
WHEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOE
PICKETT BUSINESS AGENT IBM
LOCAL ONE EIGHTY REPRESENTING
NAPA'S COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE AB
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. BUT
I AM THREE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
OUT AT. YES A GOOD MORNING-
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ONE OF.
FOR USE. ROSE OF A CAL. IN I'M
SURE IN OFFICE TO A. B. THREE
FOUR. FIVE SEVEN FOUR FIVE
PLEASE CALL BACK AT. I'M. I'M
GOING TO. RIGHT SIX THREE ONE
PLEASE AHEAD. MY NAME IS GINA
PETTIT DEBRA AND I OPPOSE THREE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. BY TO SEE
ONE THREE POINT. THE DOG HOW TO
A THREE LOOK NAME IS UP WITH TO
AB. FORTY FIVE. FOUR NINE THREE
SIXTY. PLEASE CONTACT. THERE.
YES MY NAME IS DANIEL BASS DRUM
SENIOR FACILITIES AND WITH
CHEVRON FOR AND ASK OPPOSE A.
THREE FIVE. THANK YOU SEVEN
PLEASE AHEAD. MY NAME IS DICK
BALL OVER THEIR ENERGY AND I
STRONG OPPOSE SB THREE FORTY
FIVE. BUT I'M- MIND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL HARI
COULD SHOULD THEM AND I STRONG
OPPOSE. AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. BUT I I. TWENTY PLAY
GO. RIGHT BY ZERO YOU HAD.
RIGHT ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DONALD
SANCHEZ WITH SENATOR RESOURCES
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. THREE
FORTY FIVE. NINE SIX THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI I'M
EMPLOYEE ABOUT RESOURCE MY NAME
IS A MATTHEW PERRY AND I
STRONGLY AND A THREE FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE THREE NINE. I HAD. MY
NAME IS DANNY BURKE LOCAL THREE
FOUR THREE DOLLARS TEAM
REPRESENTING NAP SLOT OKAY AND
WE JOINED BUILDING TRADES IN
OUR OPPOSITE THEY YOU. RIGHT
ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE COUNTRY WITHIN A THREE FOUR
IN STRONG UP AND OF. THREE
FORTY. THANK YOU ARE YOU ONE OF
MY FOR NEXT. ONE WELL SEVEN
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SADLY BUT I'M IN SUPPORT
CAN I REGISTER THAT NOW. SO
REGULATORS FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT SIX FOUR FOUR
EIGHT WEEKS AGO I HAD. WELL THE
ONLY FROM SIXTY SIX NICE OPPOSE
TO A. THREE FORTY FIVE. RIGHT.
FORTY TWEET I HAD. NINE FOUR
SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AND I WANT AND I I'M
PLOY OF RESEARCHERS CORP NEXT
OF. EIGHT THREE FOUR FIVE. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WELL I DON'T WANT ALL
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS EMILY
MCPHERSON SMITH WITH MACPHERSON
OIL COMPANY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL. RIGHT PLEASE
CALL BACK AT. NINE THREE SIX
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KHAN EIGHT
NAKEDNESS AGENTS OR PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS UA LOCAL FOUR
FOUR SEVEN AND I'M CALLING THE
STATE ARE ORGANIZATIONS
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SIX EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO FROM ENERGY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THREE FOUR
FIVE. RIGHT ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE SIX.
RAYMOND WATSON WITH FIELD
SERVICE COMPANY CHAMPION AXE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE UNDER PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS PATRICK
HELLO WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED B. THREE FOUR
FIVE. RIGHT FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JOHN
ONLINE WITH- CHEVRON SAM KING
THAT HE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB THREE FORTY FIVE. BUT I FOUR
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S MARK CORTINA HOBBY
AND WORKED FOR CHEVRON SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND POSED SB
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. BY
TWO THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS DIANA L. A. R.
D. WITH CLINIC RESOURCES I
STRONG OPPOSE AB. FORTY FIVE.
BY TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARK LOCAL BY
NINETY FIVE ALAMEDA COUNTY IBEW
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN THEIR OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY THREE FOUR FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE SIX TWO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE SIX TWO SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD IN. WE ARE
HEADED ON. FIVE THREE ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND GIVE
SUPPORTERS A FEW MORE MINUTES
AND WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
YEAH BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
YES LINE THREE SAT TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAD TO GET
CLEARANCE FROM THE TOP. NINE
THREE SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS FRIENDLY
MANY OF THE HALF OF THE MEMBERS
RESIDENTS TEAMSTERS LOCAL UNION
NUMBER THREE FORTY THREE OF
NAPA AND SOLANO COUNTIES.
DURING THE STATE BUILDING TRAIT
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY FIVE.
NINE TO ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KATHERINE BASHER FROM CHEVRON
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THREE
FOUR FIVE THANK YOU. BUT I
DON'T WANT SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS
KERRY WILL BE FROM BERRY
PETROLEUM I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NINE THREE EIGHT I HAD. NINE
THREE EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING BOB TAYLOR OF
COMMERCE PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR
FOUR SEVEN AM VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED A. B. THREE FORTY FIVE.
BUT I IN ONE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. K. W. DURAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL FLAVORS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU DO IT IMPACT ON
TALKING DEAD RECKONING THANK
YOU. ONE FOUR OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FOUR ZERO LINE
PLEASE CLICK BELOW AT. BY TWO
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
INCLUDE BY ANDERSON CAROL
ENERGY I'M CONSTITUENTS OF
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THREE FORTY
FIVE. NINE TWO NINETY THREE
PLEASE. MORNING SENATORS MY
NAME IS ANTHONY THIS YEAR SO ON
THE BUSINESS INTEGRITY HE OFTEN
SLATER'S LOCAL SIXTEEN
REPRESENT OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS WORKING IN FORTY SEVEN
COUNTIES IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHT FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL MARC ADDITIONAL
CAN COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
REPRESENTING TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR FINE NINETY FIVE
LET ME JUST INTERRUPT FOR A
MOMENT AS CHAIR. WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A COUPLE OF MORE CALLS IN
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION HAS HAD
MORE TIME THAN SUPPORT WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK AND CATCH
FIVE. OR SEVEN MINUTES OF
SUPPORTERS WHO WEREN'T HEARD
AND I'LL GIVE INSTRUCTIONS AT
THAT POINT WE HAVE A FULL
AGENDA TO PROCEED ANYONE WHO
WASN'T HEARD. WILL BE
ENCOURAGED TO SUBMIT THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN
WRITING- WE ARE OFFERING EQUAL
TIME ON EITHER SIDE- SO ASK THE
MODERATOR TO BRING IN A COUPLE
OF MORE IN OPPOSITION. AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE A QUICK PAUSE TO
SWITCH TO CATCH FIVE MORE
MINUTES OF SUPPORTERS BEFORE
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- THIS IS A PROTOCOL
THAT HAS BEEN PRACTICED IN
OTHER CITIES TO GET THROUGH TO.
A LONG INTENDED TODAY THANK. IN
EWING. VOICES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
WITH MILEY FROM L. ENERGY IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU I'M. FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DARBY FROM CHEVRON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY
FIVE. PINE FIVE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ABDULAHI UNDER MANNED WITH
ENERGY AND STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. THREE FOUR FIVE. BLIND ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS CHAD WALKER WITH THE
CAROL ENERGY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY FIVE.
BLIND TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JESSE GRAY
WITH THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL THREE I STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THE THREE FORTY FIVE.
CRIED ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GABRIELLE
ARAFAT FROM BERRY CORPORATION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
THREE FORTY FIVE. BY ONE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
THE ONE. BY NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MIKE COSTIGAN
I'M NOT CHRISTIAN IN THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THREE FOUR FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR I'M
NINE FIVE MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO. TAKE A PAUSE. ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION. I
APOLOGIZE WE WILL INVITE YOU TO
SUBMIT YOUR OPPOSITION IN
WRITING. TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER-
I'M GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR
NOW TO INVITE. FIVE MORE
MINUTES. FOR SUPPORTERS WHO
WEREN'T HEARD THAT WILL OFFER
EQUAL TIME ON BOTH THE SUPPORT
IN THE OPPOSITION SIDE WE WILL
THEN BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR MEMBERS-
SO THAT WE MIGHT MOVE THE
AGENDA FORWARD- ON'T AB THREE
FORTY FIVE SO MODERATOR IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO. INSTRUCT CALLERS
WHO NEED TO TAKE ANY ACTION TO
BE HEARD IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF AB THREE FOUR
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE ONLY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
RIGHT NOW IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
AND IT WOULD BE ONE MOMENT HERE.
AND WE'RE GONNA LINE SEVEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE I HAD LINDA MCCARTY
REPRESENTING NO DRILLING IN
BRENTWOOD WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHT THREE THREE FOUR FIVE WE
CARE ABOUT THE HEALTH OF THOSE
LIVING NEXT TO OIL AND GAS
WELLS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
NINE SEVEN TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL HI THIS IS CHARLIE KERR NO
I LIVE NEAR DRILLS AND ON PICO
BOULEVARD AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE FOUR FIVE.
THANK IT WOULD NEED WHY MOM.
THANK YOU ARE JUST BE ONE MORE
MOMENT WE GOT A MORE LIGHT
NUMBERS FOR SUPPORT. WHAT A
LINE FOR FIFTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. FIVE FOUR FIVE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THE
LINE THREE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND IT'LL BE JUST ONE
MORE FROM THE OTHER MORE LIGHT
NUMBERS. WE WILL TAKE TWO MORE
CALLS IN SUPPORT. AND JUST ONE
MORE MOMENT WHILE WE'RE
GATHERING MY NUMBERS.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IT'LL BE JUST
ONE MORE MOMENT. WHAT A LINE
THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I AM SHOWING MILLION IN AYE
OPPOSED AB THREE FORTY FIVE.
GAVIN NEWSOM NEED TO TAKE A
HIKE. PLEASE THE MODERATOR MOVE
TO THE NEXT CALLER THIS WILL BE
OUR LAST CALLER IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL BE BRINGING IT BACK TO
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU SEE ONE
MORE MOMENT SAID ABOUT.
EVERLIGHT ONE OH ONE. TEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS JANET **** FOUR
THREE COULD BE SILICON VALLEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND CALLERS LET ME
REMIND THOSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FORTY FIVE IN THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. WE'VE RECORDED OVER
ONE HOUR OF COMMENTS AND WE'RE
GONNA BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND A FULL
AGENDA WE INVITE ANYBODY WHO
WASN'T HEARD WITH SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY SUBMIT YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
DIRECTLY. TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER AS WE BRING IT BACK
TO THE SENATE FLOOR I WILL
RECOGNIZE MEMBERS FIRST I WILL
REPRESENT I WILL RECOGNIZE.
VICE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANNA RISE IN A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS REGARDING
THE CHAIR'S RULING ON ON
CUTTING OFF DEBATE. STAND THAT
WERE IN UNPRECEDENTED TIMES NOW
REGARDING THE PROCUMBENT TEEN
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S REACTION.
TO THAT PANDEMIC IN OUR STATE-
WHICH REQUIRES US TO HAVE-
UNPRECEDENTED MEETINGS. AND
PRESIDENT TIME FRAMES AND
UNPRECEDENTED RESTRICTIONS ON
OUR LEGISLATION. WITH THAT SAID
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
POINTED OUT CLEARLY AND I THINK
YOU HAVE ACTUALLY DONE A GOOD
JOB OF POINTING OUT THAT THERE
IS MUCH MORE- HI. FOLKS ON THE
LINE THAT ARE WISHING TO
COMMENT ON THIS BILL-
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL VERSUS
THE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT ON THE
LINE I THANK YOU FOR POINTING
THAT OUT AS WELL. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS
WATCHING IN THE COMMITTEE ARE
ALL. ADDITIONALLY IN ENCOURAGED
TO GET THEIR COMMENTS WRITTEN
AND TO THE COMMITTEE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BEFORE THIS BILL. GOES
TO THE FLOOR- ONE MORE COMMENT
I WANT TO COMMEND THE SENATE
CHAIRS AND VICE CHAIRS. UNDER
THE DIRECTION OF THE PRO TEM
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
COLLABORATIVE LEE AND ALL OF
OUR COMMITTEES ON REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF BILLS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE PAYING ATTENTION TO
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES OF
THE TIME. COVET NINETEEN
WILDFIRE RESPONSE IN
HOMELESSNESS THIS BILL DOES NOT
COMPLY WITH ANY OF THOSE THREE
ITEMS. AND IN A MEMO THAT I
SHARED WITH IT WHICH CHAIR
STERN OF THIS COMMITTEE. I
ENCOURAGED HIM- AS BEST AS I
COULD TO NOT SET THIS BILL FOR
HEARING I DON'T THINK IT
COMPLIES WITH. WHAT THE SENATE
PRO TEM AND ALL OF US AS
SENATORS HAVE AGREED. IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES OF THE-
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR STATE
TODAY. AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THOSE COMMENTS IN REGARD TO THE
RULING OF THE CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE FEW MOMENTS TO SPEAK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR HERE SIR DO LEAN- DID I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE STAFF IN
THE MODERATOR WHO HELPED
FACILITATE. TECH TO ALLOW AN A
RECORD NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE. TELL AND
IN THE THING. WHERE GOING TO
BRING THE CAR ASIAN. BACK TO
THE CA. WE'RE GOING TO TURN
FOR. TO SENATORS. JOINS US
REMOTELY. ESCAPE SENATORS
PLEASE STAND UP BY YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD IN OFF ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE FOR THE AUTHOR
OR COMMENTS ON AB FORTY FIVE-
OUR TEAM HELP BRING IN SENATOR
STERN. YES I MEAN. PLEASE
SENATOR STERN PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
UNDER. INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND PRESHEAF YOU
BEING ABLE TO SERVICE CHAIR
TODAY. IN LIGHT OF COVIDIEN MY
VERY SENSITIVE CARE TAKING
RESPONSIBILITIES I APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT BEING THERE TO HELP YOU
I DO THIS ALL IN PERSON. I ALSO
I DID TO THE VICE CHAIRS POINT
I DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
HAD CLARITY IN TERMS OF- THE
RULES OF OUR HOUSE- THAT WE'RE
WE'RE COMPLYING WITH- PRECISELY
THE SENATE'S RULES- IN TERMS OF
TESTIMONY SO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE RIGHT NOW BUT AT SOME POINT
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL-
GIVEN THE PASSION ON BOTH
SIDES. OF THIS ISSUE AND THE
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ABLE TO TESTIFY AN ASSOCIATION
WITH VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
MAY HAVE ALREADY TO. IS ONE OF.
THERE BEING IS TO. THE CURRENT
FOR THE RULING AT THIS SO- BUT
THAT'S ONE PROCEDURAL POINT I'M
HOPING WE CAN GET SOME CLARITY
ON- IT IS SUBSTANTIVE LEVEL
HERE ON THIS LEGISLATION. I
THINK THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO
BE HEARD RIGHT NOW AT THIS
MOMENT. DESPITE THE CODE CRISIS
GOING ON AND ACTUALLY BECAUSE
OF IT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING ACTION.
IN THIS SPACE AND THE
OPPOSITION OF THE PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IS CORRECT THAT
THERE ALREADY IS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING UNDER
WAY AND SO SOME OF YOU MAY ASK
THEN WHY IS THIS NECESSARY I
THINK TO THE LEGISLATURE HAVING
POLICY DIRECTION AND CONTROL
OVER MAJOR ISSUES AFFECTING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE HELD THIS NEAR
AND DEAR TO PEOPLE WORKING IN
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY AND
PEOPLE WHO LIVE NEAR THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY- THERE IS
URGENCY TO THIS- THESE JOBS ARE
REAL RIGHT NOW THIS CHEN IS
REAL RIGHT NOW IN THE CLIMATE
CRISIS IS VERY MUCH HERE RIGHT
NOW. THIS IS NOT SO. I THINK WE
SHOULD BE. TO IT. TO PROCEED
WITH A AND ALL DUE RESPECT
BECAUSE I SINCERELY ADMIRE- THE
GOVERNOR'S INITIATIVE ON THIS
AS WELL AS OUR LEADERSHIP AT
BOTH CALLIE PA AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY I THINK
THEY'VE LAID OUT A- AN EVIDENCE
BASED FRAMEWORK. I DON'T THINK
THIS BILL CONTRAVENES THAT I DO
THINK THERE MAY BE A DIFFERENT
OPINIONS AND ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES. TO ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE AND I WELCOME THAT DEBATE
AMONG THE MEMBERS I THINK
THAT'S A VERY HEALTHY
CONVERSATION TO HAVE IN TERMS
OF- YOU KNOW HOW HOW YOU LAY
OUT A FRAMEWORK. DO YOU TO
MANDATE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
FOOTAGE FOR SET BACK DO YOU
REQUIRE SET BACK AT ALL- IS
THERE A BETTER WAY. TO REGULATE
OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS ON
STRICT HEALTH AND SAFETY BASIS
I THINK THERE ARE- VALLEY VIEW
POINTS- ON BOTH ON ALL SIDES OF
THAT ISSUE I TAKE. THE AUTHORS
LEGISLATION TO HEW VERY CLOSELY
TO THE PENNY ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTION- IF YOU'LL NOTICE A LOT
OF THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL IS
SHALL QUE PETER. SO THE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED THAT I KNOW IS.
CONCERT TWO. MANY OF OUR
CALLERS IN MANY OF THE STATE
CALL HERE I UNDERSTAND THAT TO
BE- NOT A MANDATORY US AMOUNT
OF SET BACK BUT THE AMOUNT THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED IN THE
PRECEDING I THINK THAT'S A
THAT'S A HEALTHY AN IMPORTANT
METRIC TO UNDERTAKE IS A
CONSIDERATION BUT I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T
MANDATE THAT- I ALSO DON' SEE
ANYTHING IN CURRENT LAW THAT
WOULD STATE THAT. IS NURSES
EARLIER TAKING AND I THINK
PRESIDENT THEY SHOWN THAT IN.
THE MANY OTHER STATES AROUND
THIS COUNTRY THAT HAVE SUCH
SETBACKS- WE TRIED TO IN THESE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF ZONING AND
LOCAL. ADMINISTRATORS IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE LAND
USE ISSUES BEYOND THEIR IMPACT
ON STATE OIL AND GAS AND
CLIMATE POLICY OTHER CERTAINLY
IS- IMPACT ON LOCAL LAND USE
AND ESPECIALLY THE TIME WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING- IN OUR BACKYARDS. I
EAT I AGREE WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SAYING
THERE SHOULD BE. YES IN MY BACK
WHEN IT COMES TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT NO IN MY BACKYARD
BECOMES THE MORAL AND GASTRIC.
BY I GO TO. A LOT OF PLACES
THAT LA AND IT MAKES ME VERY
ANXIOUS- TO BE WITH. FAMILY
FRIENDS LOVED ONES- IN A PLACE
THAT I CAN'T ASSURE THEM IS
COMPLETELY SAFE AND WE WENT
THROUGH THAT A VERY PERSONAL
WAY WITH THE LEAST SO CANYON
THIS BILL ISN'T STRICTLY
LIMITED TO OIL OPERATIONS IT
ALSO INCLUDES. A GAS OPERATIONS
AND THE PROXIMITY OF A LEASE SO
CANYON TO A SUBURBAN COMMUNITY-
SHOULD GIVE YOU STARK EVIDENCE
AND REMINDERS NOT JUST THE
PEOPLE LIVE THERE THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN
LITIGATION OVER THE POLLUTION
THEY FACED AS A RESULT OF THAT
URBAN FACED IN GAS FIELD. AND
NUMEROUS OTHER OPERATIONS
INCLUDING ALLEN CO IN THE HEART
OF BELLAY WHICH WAS JUST CITED
UNDER CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
THEIR NOT ENDURANCE THE STATE
REQUIREMENT- IT THIS MORNING OR
LAST NIGHT BY THE CITY ATTORNEY
MIKE FEWER. SO I EVERY THIS IS
A TOUGH TO- AND I READ AND I
READ TRULY DO RESPECT THE
DIFFERENT VIEWS ON IT BUT I
THINK TO DO A BIG DEAL WE
REALLY SHOULD NOT AVOID. AND I
DO WELL THANK CONVERSE BECAUSE
WE FOR I AYE BE TO PREVENT IS
HERE. IN THE NEXT WHILE IF FOR
HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS
ALTERNATIVE CONCEPTS BUT I
REALLY THINK THAT THE BILL IN
HERE IS DOLLARS. AND WORTH.
PASSING TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATORS. IN I HEAR THAT AS A
COMMENTARY WITH YOUR
OBSERVATIONS NO QUESTION
DIRECTED TO THE AUTHOR- I DO
NOW RECOGNIZED IN THE QUEUE I
HAVE SENATOR HERTZBERG FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR JACKSON. IN THEN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR GORGEOUS.
CENTER HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN. BOMB. I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT YOU KNOW. WE HAVE HAD
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES. WITH AN
AGENCY CALLED DOGGER. WE HAD
LEADERSHIP FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF THE MOLD LAST YEAR IN AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN. BUT NOT JUST
RENAME THE AGENCY BUT ALSO
REFOCUSED IT TO DEAL WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND I WANT TO
SPEAK AS WE SPEAK HERE TODAY
AND ON THIS MEASURE TALK TO
KATIE VALENZUELA AND WHAT SHE
SAID IF SHE STILL LISTENING OR
RUBEN RODRIGUEZ IF HE'S
LISTENING. AND THE THOUSAND
GRANDMOTHERS THE JACQUI COLD
GOLDBERG TOLD ME WE'RE
LISTENING THAT MY FRIENDS FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. TEXTED
ME AND PAGED AND CALLED. AND I
WANT TO TAKE A SERIOUS APPROACH
TO WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
BECAUSE IN MY EXPERIENCE IN
THIS BUILDING OFTEN MEASURES.
TAKE ON A WHOLE LIFE OF THEIR
OWN. THAT IS INCONSISTENT WITH.
AND IN CONTRAVENTION WITH. WHAT
THE LAW ACTUALLY SAYS. AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD ME THOSE WHO WORK
WITH THE FOR MANY YEARS WHAT'S
THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE. LET'S LOOK JUST FOR A
MOMENT THROUGH THE TEN THE
ELEMENTS ARE GO FAST. WHAT THIS
BILL SAYS. AND HOW IT WAS HOW
WE AS A GOVERNMENT. ARE
RESPONDING TO THE VERY CONCERNS
THAT PEOPLE CARE ABOUT. THE
FIRST ONE SAYS. SECTION TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT OH FIVE POINT
FOR THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES EXIST TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCE
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS GAPS IN EXISTING
PROGRAMS POLICIES AND
ACTIVITIES THAT MAY IMPEDE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. I SUPPORT IT A 100%
CORRECT THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AT EVERY LEVEL. BUT WHAT THIS
BILL DOESN'T SAY AND WHAT IN
FURY H. ME AS A LEGISLATOR IS I
HAVE BEEN CROSSED. THAT WILL IN
THIS LEGISLATURE JUST PASSED BY
MAJORITY. AND IF YOU LOOK AT IT
HE CREATES ESTABLISHES A
POSITION OF ASSISTANT SECRETARY
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IF
YOU LOOK AT SB SEVENTY FOUR ON
PAGE NINETY SIX. A MEASURE THAT
THIS BODY PASSED IT SETS FORTH
IN APPROPRIATIONS FOR THAT
MONEY. SO WE'VE GOT THIS ENERGY
AND WE'VE GOT THIS ANXIETY
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ASKING FOR A
VOICE IN A BAR MENTAL JOB THIS.
AND IS- THIS LEGISLATION HAS
DONE EXACTLY THAT. I AM TIRED
OF BILLS JUST PUSH PEOPLE'S
BUTTONS AND PUSH PEOPLE'S
NERVES AND SO I SAY THE CAT
KITTY BALANCE WAIVER AND RUBEN
RODRIGUEZ MORE ON THE GAME
WE'RE DOING THIS WE HAVE PUT IN
THE BERMAN. BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
VOICE SOMETHING IS TO HAPPEN
BEFORE. IT IS COMPLETELY WRONG
TO BE ABLE TO PUT LEGISLATION
FORWARD IN MY JUDGMENT THAT IS
ALREADY BEEN ACTED ON BY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THIS GOVERNMENT
TO BE ABLE TO TRY TO TOUCH
PEOPLE'S BUTTONS THAT IT'S
WRONG LET. ME WALK THROUGH THE
REST OF IT. THREE FOUR. BECAUSE
THIS PARA CUMPLIR TALK ABOUT IN
FEES BUT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
THERE'S NO TO EVEN TALK ABOUT
THAT RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF THIS
YEAR BECAUSE IT SAYS UPON
FUNDING IN THE FUNDING STUFF
ISSUES ARE OVER TO RELEVANT
IT'S NOISE. PARAGRAPH THREE IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. IT SAYS
HONOR BEFORE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE DEPARTMENT
ADOPT REGULATIONS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY NEAR
OIL AND GAS FIELDS. J. JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO OKAY
IT'S NOT AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
GOVERNMENT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR GOVERNMENT. THE REALITY IS
IF YOU GOT IT THERE'S NOTHING
IN THIS MEASURE THAT SAYS WE
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING IT'S JUST
DOT REGULATIONS GUESS WHAT AS A
RESULT OF WHAT WE NEED LIMóN
DID IT RESTART WISHING THIS AS
A RESULT OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
HIS NEW DIRECTION AS A RESULT
OF WHAT WAIT CROWFOOT IS DOING
HIS DEPARTMENT. THEY'RE ON THE
JOB. AND SO IF YOU WANT TO TAKE
AND MAKE SURE THAT EQUITY
KERR'S IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
FORTY THOUSAND COMMENTS.
HEARINGS IN SPANISH AND ENGLISH.
THIS CALLS FOR RULEMAKING THE
WAY RULEMAKING WORKS IS YOUR
FIRST LISTEN TO EVERYBODY GET A
PRE RULEMAKING GUESS WHAT WE'VE
HAD A BUNCH HEARINGS AND GUESS
WEN THE NEXT ONE IS IT'S TOM
MORROW TOMORROW LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. SO WE HAVE IN THE
MAKING AND THEN YOU GO TO THE
LEGAL EVIDENCE FREE PROCESS
THAT TAKES ABOUT A YEAR. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABSOLUTELY
BASED UPON WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LIMON DID IS ON TRACK
TO DO THIS. THIS BILL.
VALENZUELA RUBEN HEARD. DIPS IF
AND EVERY OTHER GROUP DOES THIS
SLOWER THAN WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING IT IT DOESN'T ACHIEVE THE
WEEK THE PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE IT GETS WE GET INTO
THESE ARGUMENTS AND IT RATHER
THAN TO ME ISSUES DO THE
HOMEWORK DO THE HOMEWORK READ
THE BILL DOUBLE CHECK
EVERYTHING AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING. PARAGRAPH FOUR DEVILISH
MINIMUM SETBACK DISTANCES AND
THAT IS THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE SAYS THE DEPARTMENT
SHALL CONSIDER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEET TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEET SUPPORT TERM BUT
DOESN'T REQUIRE IT IT SAYS
SHALL CONSIDER IT WHAT IS THE
GOVERNOR SAY. THE GOVERNOR SAYS
THAT THE RULEMAKING WILL
CONSIDER DOESN'T SAY SHALL
CONSIDER. IT WILL SPECIFICALLY
TO ME WITH ONE OF THE DEBATES
WE HAVE ON THIS FOR ALL THE
TIME. NOW WE'RE COMMITTEE. IS A
DIFFERENCE HE SHALL MAY THEN
WILL WILL BEING THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THAT POLICY.
THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S
STATEMENT YOU CAN CALL IT A
PRESS RELEASE BUT THE COACH
DIRECTLY FROM THE GOVERNOR
DIRECTLY TO THE SECRETARY OF
RESOURCES. AND BY THE WAY IF
THEY DON'T DO WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO WHEN SESSION NEXT YEAR HEY
WE CAN KICK THEIR **** WE HAVE
THAT ABILITY BECAUSE OF COURSE.
RULEMAKINGS NOT REQUIRED UNTIL.
JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. UNDER
THIS THING. AND CURRENTLY
THEY'RE ON TRACK TO GET THIS
DONE. WITHIN A YEAR ADVANCE OF
WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR. THE
RULEMAKING WILL CONSIDER A
RANGE OF PROTECTIVE MEASURES.
INCLUDING PROHIBITING OIL AND
GAS ACTIVITIES WITHIN CLOSE
PROXIMITY OF HOMES. SCHOOLS
HOSPITALS AND PARKS. THE PRE
REGULATORY PROCESS WILL BEGIN
IN TWENTY TWENTY IT DID. BY THE
WAY THE DATA. A. J. NOVEMBER.
SENATE MODIFIED RULES OKAY
THEY'RE DOING IT THERE'S NO
NEED FOR US TO SPEND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. YOU HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT EVIDENCE
THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTEREST IN
THIS ISSUE AND IS MOVING AT
BREAKNECK SPEED I'M ALMOST
FINISHED INSTRUMENT THESE I
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR BECAUSE-
EVERY ONE OF THESE ELEMENTS
WERE ALREADY DOING THIS IS NOT
A BILL. ESTABLISHES LAW IT'S
JUST NOT WHAT IT DOES NOT WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT REACHED OUT TO
ME BY CONSTITUENTS THE COUPLE
DOZEN LAWMAKERS IN LA. THE IT'S
IN DEVELOPING THIS WILL IT WILL
LOOK AT THE BEST AVAILABLE DATA
AND SCIENCE AGAIN IF YOU READ
NOVEMBER NINETEENTH IT
SPECIFICALLY QUOTES THAT BUT
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
RELY ON THE TALKS ABOUT FOR PRE
RULEMAKING DECISIONS THEY'RE
ALREADY DONE. ASKING FOR
SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE IT'S
ALREADY DONE. AND THEN IT SAYS
THIS IS THE REAL KICKER. ON OR
BEFORE JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THE DEPARTMENT SHALL
PROVIDE AN UPDATE. ON THE
PROCESS. AND THE SCRIPTING OF
THE REGULATIONS BEING
CONSIDERED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCE AND WATER THIS
COMMITTEE. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DONE BY THAT PERIOD OF TIME. SO
YOU KNOW WHEN I LOOK AT THIS
BILL. I UNDERSTAND IT TOUCHES
NERVES. I GET IT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED THIS MOVE MY WHOLE
LIFE. BY LEFT GOVERNMENT LAST
TIME I WAS HERE AND I SPENT MY
WHOLE LIFE WORKING IN.
ENVIRONMENTAL SPACE IN VARIOUS
ITERATIONS IN COUNTRIES THAT.
ARE POOR AND HAVE HUGE
CHALLENGES. IT'S IN MY HEART
IT'S WHAT I'M ABOUT. BUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IS NOTHING.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING. THE AUTHOR
THIS BILL SENT ME A TEXT LAST
NIGHT AT FIVE THIRTY TO FOUR PM
SAID DO THE RIGHT THING IS THE
RIGHT THING TO READ THE BILL IS
THE RIGHT THING TO READ THE
BUDGET IS THE RIGHT THING TO
TELL THE TRUTH. THIS IS NOT
THAT. I LIVE NEAR A BE MY I
REPRESENT COMMITTEES NEARLY SO
CANYON I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THESE FIGHTS I AM A BELIEVER
BUT I AM BUT I HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS REPUBLIC
TO DO THE HOMEWORK TO TELL THE
TRUTH THE STAND TALL FOR THE
VALUES YOU BELIEVE IN BUT DO IT
BASED UPON DOING THE HOMEWORK.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THAT I'D LOVE TO HEAR RESPONSES
BY THE AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE I'VE ONE PARAGRAPH BY
PARAGRAPH I HAD THE BILL
CERTAINLY STUDY IN A WHOLE
BUNCH OF OTHER STUDIES HAVE
LOOKED AT. MARCH I'M. UNLESS
YOU JUST DON'T BELIEVE THIS
GOVERNOR YOU THINK THE
SECRETARY RESOURCE A LIAR AND
YOU THINK THAT THEY'RE NOT
MOVING FAST AND YOU THINK THAT
THE ALLOCATION IN THE BUDGET IS
FALSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
THANK YOU SENATOR TOM LET ME
SEE IF THE AUTHOR IS TO RESPOND
AT THIS POINT OR WOULD YOU
PREFER TO. DO IT IN YOUR
CLOTHES. I CAN RESPOND OUT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE TO. THE MAJORITY
LEADER. TAKEN A CLOSE LOOK AT
AT THIS BILL I KNOW THAT HE IS
A- VERY THOUGHTFUL- AND
EXPERIENCE POLICY MAKER AND I
RESPECT HIS OPINION- BUT I MUST.
BY IN TERMS OF HIS CHARACTER
CREATION OF THIS BILL DOING
NOTHING. HE DIDN'T MAKE THE
POINT. THAT THE GOVERNOR. HAS
ISSUED HIS PRESS RELEASE- WHERE
HE SAID HE WILL CONSIDER. SOME
SET BACK A PUBLIC HEALTH INS IN
SAFETY BUFFER ZONES TO PROTECT
THESE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING BY REQUIRING. ON
SETBACK DISTANCES THOSE ARE TWO
AND VERY CLEAR DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN CONSIDERING A SET BACK
AND THIS LEGISLATURE MAKING
THIS MEANT THAT LIKE IT'S A
CROP FREE WE SHALL REQUIRE
MINIMUM SET DISTANCE BETWEEN
OIL AND GAS ACTIVITIES AND
SENSITIVE LAPIDES THIS SO. HI I
WOULD JUST TO. AT THIS POINT TO
MAKE THEIR CLEAR THIS IT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR IS HAS ANNOUNCED
WHAT THE SECTOR OF NATURAL
RESOURCES IS WORKING ON AND
WHAT THIS BILL REQUIRES. NEXT
IN ORDER SENATOR JACK IN THE
FIRST. THANK YOU NOT SURE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES-
MY SENSE IS IF THIS BILL DIDN'T
DO ANYTHING WE WOULDN'T OF HAD
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE ON THE LINE
MORNING TO TALK ABOUT IT. WHEN
THEY'RE- IS SAID IS A
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE A DUTY NOT
TO ABDICATE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES OUR VALUES AND
OUR POLICY MAKING- TO ANY OTHER
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT. WE ARE
ALL CùNG INCHES WE ALL THIS
FUNCTIONS. I THINK IT'S A THERE
BE ARE SURE WITH THE GOVERNOR
OUR PRIORITIES AND I THINK THE
PRIORITY IN THIS BILL OF
CONSIDERING SAFETY. AND HEALTH.
AS IN A INVITE. ARE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WORLD
WHERE MY WE KNOW THAT MOST OF
THESE FACILITIES ARE BUILT IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO KNOW THROUGH MODERN
SCIENCE AND RESEARCH AND
MEDICINE THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT SUBSTANTIAL
ADVERSE. IMPACTS TO
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN'S HEALTH
AND THE HEALTH OF VULNERABLE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY LIVE NEAR
THESE FACILITIES. OUR THIS IS A
MEASURE AS I UNDERSTANDIT THAT
IGNORE ALLEGES THAT. THAT SAYS
ARE THERE SHALL BE SETBACKS AND
NO INITIALLY IT'S SAID THAT
THEY WILL BE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEET OR MORE MY
INTEREST IS THAT HAS BEEN A-
THE L. THE EXPERT. SITTARD THE
SHALL BE SET PROJECT. IN AREAS
OF WHERE THEIR SCHOOLS CHILD
CARE CENTERS. THESE ARE ARE
THESE ARE CHILDREN THESE ARE
OUR FUTURE AND THE- THAT WE
HAVE NOT THAT WE- I THINK ONE
OF THE ONLY OR THE ONLY STATE
IN THE COUNTRY WHERE. OIL
PULLING THE- ACT. TO ME THAT'S.
STOPPING BECAUSE WE YOU LOOK AT
OR- PRODUCING STATE. THEY CHEN
ARE NOT IS COMMITTED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AS WE ARE
HERE. SO I WOULD HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY. HI THIS WITH THE
NOTION THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
ROLE IN THIS I THINK WE HAVE A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THIS- THERE
WAS A COMMENT MADE ABOUT HALL
ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE WORK
OPPOSITION I'VE BEEN ADVISED
IN. THIS IS PERFECT OUR- GET ON
YOU KNOW YOU. A STAND IN A
QUEUE. DAN OF CATION WORRY
DISTINGUISH SUPPORT FOR
OPPOSITION I'M TOLD THAT THE
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF GROUPS
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO WANTED TO
GIVE THERE'S- A TAPE TO EXPRESS
IT SO I'M GOING TO LIST A FEW
OF THEM. I THINK IT'S PRETTY
GIVEN VICE CHAIR. BUT ALL THIS
IS IN OUR NATION THE BILL YOU
HAD THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE
THE FIVE JURISTS INSTITUTE THE
CENTER FOR ALL SHE SHE HAD
ACQUIRED THIS RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION. BAY IN CAP. SO. SHE
PLASTIC OCEANS BASHAM PLUS
POLLUTION COAL. SAVE OUR SHOW
SEVENTY. ADVICE UPSTREAM STORY
CHUMASH FUND OF MY DISTRICT
ZERO WASTE USA THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
VOICES FOR PROGRESS THREE FIFTY
AREA ACT. FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIA THREE FIFTY
RIVERSIDE GREEN ACTION FOR
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE BY NATIONAL SHOULD.
DEVELOPMENT I'M SORRY. WHAT
PART I THINK IT IS WHAT INDEED
COMMUNITIES. GREENPEACE SA OIL
CHANGE USA STANDING TOGETHER
AGAINST NEIGHBORHOOD RULING
COALITION. IN THIS IN COUNTY OF
WASHING. THREE FIFTY RIVER
SUNRISE BAY SUNRISE GILLETTE
INVOICE PRAGUE WAS ARE JUST
AMONG THE GROUP AND DID NOT GET
IT TO. SO I SAY THAT CLERK TO
CLEAR THE RECORD AND TO WITH
THAT UP IN MARIN MIDDLE JUSTICE
WE KNOW THE IMPACT OF WHAT NO
THAT CONSERVE. IS A BILL TO
REQUIRE THAT WE LOOK AT IT AND
PUT IT. BEING OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND IT CALLED WORLD WE HAVE THE
SEPTA UNITIES ARE MY CAR OF.
THE CAR. OF WAR. WE COMMUNITIES
OR NEAR THEIR COMING. THIS IS
CLEARLY INITIAL. PROPRIO
BROUGHT HERE TODAY ARE N. DOT
APPRECIATE THE OFF BRING IN
BILL AND WILL VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR I WILL ROOM BOTH
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS IF
YOU'RE- COMMENTARY WASN'T HEARD
TODAY YOU ARE WELCOME TO SUBMIT
IN WRITING TO THE NATURAL. IN
ORDER IT WILL BE THIRD. IN TWO
NOTED AS PER OF THE PER. TODAY
RIGHT NOW MOVING TO SENATOR
PORCHES YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER. I HAVE TO SAY
WHEN I HEAR THE MAJORITY LEADER
OF PUT UP IS MIKE AND SPEAK SO
FORCEFULLY ON AN ISSUE.
CAPTURES MY ATTENTION. WHAT I
HEARD FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER
ON THIS BILL IS THAT IT. UNDER
DELIVERS AND IS NOT TERRIBLY
RELEVANT TO THE MORE
SIGNIFICANT- EXECUTIVE ACTIONS
THAT ARE OCCURRING RIGHT NOW.
SO I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
POLITICAL BACKGROUND UNDERSTAND
ALL THE AGREEMENTS AND ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS AND DEVELOPMENTS
POLITICAL DEVELOPMENTS THAT
HAVE GONE ON. THE SUBJECT
MATTER. BUT THAT DOES GIVE ME
PAUSE THAT IF THE GOVERNOR AND
ALL THE INSTRUMENTALITY IS
GOVERNMENT. ARE MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION ALBEIT EVEN QUICKER
THAN THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WOULD ALLOW THEN I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A AS A STEP BACK
SAYING WE- CLING DO ANYTHING OF
REAL SIGNIFICANCE HERE. AND IF
NOT WE SHOULD. SERIOUSLY TO
VIOLATE WHETHER OR NOT THIS
BILL SHOULD HAVE EVEN BEEN
HEARD TODAY. AND I IN MIND. IN
THIS. IS THAT THE BIG OF THE
CALL EXPERIENCE WE WERE OUT BY
LEADERSHIP IN WRITING AND
ORALLY TO DRUM. RE ORIENT
JUSTLY TO FOCUS TO THE IT THAT
ONE SIGNIFICANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FIRST AND FOREMOST
KOBE NINE RELATED MATTERS
WILDFIRES HOMELESSNESS THAT
EVENTUALLY GOT PARED DOWN TO
DOES THIS HAVE A EMERGENCY
INSIGNIFICANCE A COMPONENT
ESPECIALLY IN THE COVERED
CONTACT. I WOULD FROM TWELVE
BILLS DOWN TO TWO I KNOW MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES- HEEDED THOSE
RECOMMEND BY THE PRO TEM AND
SIMILARLY DRAMATICALLY SCALED
BACK THEIR LEGISLATIVE PACK. SO
IF THAT WAS THE DIRECTION OF
THIS BODY AND I BELIEVE THERE
WAS COUNTERPART DIRECTION FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AS WELL. WHY
ARE WE LOOKINGAT A BILL LIKE
THIS. DURING A PANDEMIC. THAT'S
FIRST AND FOREMOST I'M NOT EVEN
CERTAIN THIS SHOULD EVEN HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT FORWARD IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE THEY SHOULD
PROBABLY BE WHICH TO BE
DEFERRED I THINK TO JANUARY.
THE SECOND IS. WHAT IS THE COST.
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS. THAT WE
TALK ABOUT SETBACKS I HAVE TWO
LITTLE BOYS. WHO WERE IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL I EIGHTY I'M
HERE I CAME FROM A FAMILY OF
EDUCATORS I HAVE A SOFT SPOT
MAKING CERTAIN THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF OUR
CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I THINK SET AS I AM IN MY
PREVIOUS COOPER ON THE OF
SUPERVISORS IN A FIRE CON. AT
BELIEVE THAT. LOOKING AT EIGHT
UNDER. THIS OF ORACLE. IN THIS
ED EXPERIENCE. NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WELLS AND
EXTRACTION SITES BEING SHUT
DOWN TO THE TUNE OF I THINK ONE
BEST WAS 60% 66% THE OIL AND
GAS WELLS IN LEE COUNTY ALL.
DOWN MY BRAIN IDEA THAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE LOOKING AFTER
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND WELFARE
IN A COVERT CONTEXT. YET
SIMULTANEOUSLY BEING PREPARED
TO SHED THOUSANDS OF JOBS WHEN
UNEMPLOYMENT. HAS SKYROCKETED
EDT HAS NOT BEEN PERFORMING AT
A LEVEL THAT IS MAKING OUR
COMMUNITIES- RELATIVELY
FUNCTION. MY LAST POINT ON THIS.
WHAT DOES A GLORIA
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM TO HELP
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATE IN
AGENCY REGULATORY PROCESSES.
I'VE BEEN AROUND GOVERNMENT
LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE LANGUAGE LIKE THAT
INCORPORATED INTO. BILL I
BECOME SUSPICIOUS. IF IT'S TRUE
TRULY ABOUT HEALTH AND WELFARE.
ABOUT MAKING CERTAIN THAT
THERE'S A SETBACK BETWEEN
EXTRACTION SITES IN SCHOOLS
EXTRACTION SITES AND HOSPITALS.
THAT GIVING MONEY TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS TO
BECOME ADVOCATES ARE IN IT IN
ADVANCE. A POLITICAL AGENDA I'M
NOT SO CERTAIN IS THE USE OF
TAXPAYER MONEY. SO WHEN YOU ADD
IT ALL UP THIS IS COVE IN
NINETEEN RELATED. THIS IS GOING
TO SHED JOBS AT THE WORST TIME
POSSIBLE IT'S GIVING MONEY AWAY
TO ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS TO
PURSUE A- LEGISLATIVE SET OF.
ORDERS I THINK SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE WITHDRAWN IN
BROUGHT BACK IN JANUARY AND ON
TOP OF THAT I'D LOVE TO SEE A
COST ESTIMATE THAT IF ALL THESE
EXTRACTION SITES WERE SHUT DOWN.
WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN TO OUR
ECONOMY TO OUR EMPLOYEES INTO
THOSE THAT RELY ON THAT SOURCE
OF INCOME. THANK YOU SENATE
MOVING NEXT SENATOR WAY SO YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK HELLO
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE HAVING
THIS DEBATE UNNECESSARILY TODAY
I THINK THE POINT WAS MADE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE ASSIST UNDER
THAT'S MUCH MORE DETAIL THAN
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL THAT
WILL MORE THAN IN THIS BILL
WILL PLUS. ONLY THE THAT
PROCESS WHICH I DON'T SUPPORT.
BUT I DO WANT TO SPY I THINK I
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION OF WHY
WE'RE HERE IN AND OUT IT'S NOT
A IT'S NOT A GOOD ANSWER
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT NOT TO
PLEASE WILL LIVE. HERE THIS IS
ACTUALLY A WASTE OF EVERYBODY'S
TIME UNFORTUNATELY. AND I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE TO EVERYBODY THAT
HAD CALLED IN TODAY I. WANNA
APOLOGIZE FOR EVERYONE IN THE
PUBLIC FOR THIS. THIS THIS
EXERCISE IT REALLY WILL NOT
REALLY ACHIEVE. ANYTHING AT ALL
WHEN YOU WERE HERE. BUT TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNMENT GOVERNORS
ARE TAKING. AND HOW DETAILED IT
IS AND HOW. IT'S GONNA DRESS
SOME OF THE YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL.
SEEKS TO DO CERTAIN THINGS BUT
SO DOES THE INTENT OF THE WORK
OF THE GOVERNOR AND I THINK
IT'S MORE DETAILED AND I THINK
IT'S A- HOME THE WORK OF THE
GOVERNMENT I THINK IS AT LEAST
MORE CLEAR THAN WHAT IS BILL
THIS BILL IS BROUGHT BILL IS
NOT CLEAR THE BILL REALLY DOES
NOT AYE DIRECTION SO WE GET THE
LEGISLATURE. IT PROVIDING THE
WE NEED DETAILED. BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR HAS TO BE PRESENTED
MORE DETAILED DIRECTION BUT
THIS LADIES AND GENTLEMAN IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A PUBLICITY
STUNT AND AT A TIME WHEN WE
CANNOT. THANK TWO BILLION HERE
THE RULES THAT WERE SET UP BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO ONLY WORK ON
BILLS. THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
CURRENTLY TO THE STATE I
INTRODUCED FOURTEEN BILLS THIS
YEAR I'M DOWN TO ONE. ONE BILL
I USED A LOT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
BILLS BILLS THAT WOULD HELP OUR
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA WHY DID
THOSE BILLS DIE AND WHY ARE WE
HEARING THIS ONE. WHY IS THIS
BILL IMPORTANT IN MY BILLS ON
THE ENVIRONMENT I HAD A BILL
THAT WAS GOING TO HELP TO
RECYCLE PLASTIC. AND ALSO
CREATE JOBS AND ALL. REMOVE
PLASTIC FROM OUR OCEANS AND
RIVERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES I HAD
A BILL. THAT WAS GOING TO HELP.
CHILDREN GET ACCESS TO.
AFFORDABLE INTERNET. AT A TIME
RIGHT NOW I GOT A I GOT A CALL
FROM THE SUPERINTENDENT
EDUCATION TALKING ABOUT HOW
THERE ARE SO MANY CHILDREN ARE
STATE THAT HAVE STARTED SCHOOL
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET I WAS THAT BILL TAKE.
A THAT IS A CO PLAYED A BILL
YEAH WE CAN'T DISCUSS IT BUT
WE'RE ALREADY DISCUSSING THIS
BILL. THAT WILL REALLY DO
NOTHING THAT WERE NOT ALREADY
WORKING ON THERE'S A SLEW OF
BILLS THAT I SUPPORTED S. B.
THIRTY TWO BY HELP BE BEST FOR
BY. THE ONE EIGHTY NINE FOR AYE
GARCIA. SO MANY BILLS DEAL WITH.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL TESTS THAT I
HAVE SUPPORTED OVER THE YEARS
AND I'M GLAD STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT AND NOT JUST. TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES. FOR POOR
QUALITY. FIVE I NEVER MISSED OF
A- IT'S VERY HARD FOR ME TO
STAND. AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
AUTHOR AND HIS MOTIVES BUT I
HAVE NOTHING MORE THAN TO
RELIEVE. SEN HERE IN
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT WE'RE
HAVING THIS LENGTHY DEBATE. A
LENGTHY DEBATE ABOUT A BILL
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN.
ADJUDICATED THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I JUST THAT I
FOR THAT. VERY DISAPPOINTING.
ALL BILLS BUT I. HAVE WORKED ON
ARE DOWN TO ONE. DOWN AT I'M
STILL STRUGGLE TO GET A- FOR
THAT BILL AND SO YET WE'RE HERE
DISCUSSING BILL THAT'S ALREADY
IN THE WORKSTO BE RESOLVED.
THAT WE WORK HARD TO PUSH.
STATE TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
FOR MANY YEARS WE WERE FINALLY
THERE AND THEN WE HAVE A DEBATE
ON THIS. BILL UNNECESSARILY AND
MISTER CHAIR I'M JUST
FRUSTRATED SORRY FOR MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU SHARE THE
COMMENTS. SEEING NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE I WILL TO EXERCISE
THE PROGRESS OF THE CHAIRED
OFFER A COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS
AND TURN IT TO THE OFFICE. FOR
HIS CLOTHES. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE RESPECTFUL
NATURE. OF THE ENGAGEMENT AND
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO. HATED
REMOTELY. A LITTLE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS LEGISLATION
I DO SEE VERY DIRECT CODE
NINETEEN NEXT. WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TRENDS OF COVERT NINETEEN
INFECTION AND DEATHS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IT IS HIGHER AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IT'S
BASED ON SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
WHERE WE HAVE COMMUNITIES. OF
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OFTEN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO ALSO
LIVE IN THE MOST TOXIC. WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATES ASTHMA WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST RATES OF OTHER
CHILDHOOD DISEASE AND CLUSTERS
OF CANCER. AND NOT SURPRISINGLY
WE FIND THOSE OFTEN PROXIMITY.
TO OIL EXTRACTION IN OIL
PRODUCTION. ONE THING THAT'S
DISTURBING TO ME. IT SAID AS WE
FACE COVERT NINE. IT IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS JUST AS
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND THEY
CONVERGE. IN THE FOLLOWING
MANNER THE CLIMATE CRISIS
PEOPLE OFTEN LOOK TO AS BEING
PROSPECTIVE IT'S IN FRONT OF US
FRIENDS IT IS HERE RIGHT NOW
AND IT EXACERBATES WHETHER.
WATER IMPACTS IN OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT AFFECT
DISADVANTAGED. COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. LABOUR RIGHTFULLY RISES
WITH CONCERN OF JOB LOSS AND
DISPLACEMENT. AND YET FOR THE
FUTURE OF OUR COMMUNITIES. THAT
SAME WORKFORCE LIVES IN
COMMUNITIES THAT FACE SIMILAR
PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS. WE NEED TO
EMERGE FROM THIS CONVERSATION
AND FIND THE PATHWAYS WHERE
LABOR AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY. HE WE
TOGETHER. TOOK GOOD PAYING
MIDDLE CLASS UNION JOBS WORKING
IN CLEAN ENERGY SECTOR AND
WE'VE SEEN THAT TRANSITION
HAPPENING MANY IN THE BUILDING
TRADES ARE WORKING IN CLEAN
ENERGY PRODUCTION WE ALSO NEED
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT.
IN THAT ARENA BUT DIFFER ON THE
SUGGESTION THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT NOT COVERT
NINETEEN RELATED IF WE LOOK AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT. I'VE
COVERED NINETY. HE RECOMMEND
THE SUGGESTION CONTAINED IN
THIS LEGISLATION ADDRESS THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS HEAD ON I
WILL URGE AN AYE VOTE IN I WILL.
NOW TO THE AUTHOR FOR HIS CALL
THANK HIM FOR HIS PATIENTS- IN
BRINGING THE BILL TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MISTER AUTHOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- STRONG. WORDS
POURED FOR THIS BILL I THINK OF.
YOU HAVE ADDRESSED AND I WOULD-
ECHO- YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT THE
DIRECT NEXUS BETWEEN THIS BILL
AND BECAUSE OF IT. YOU KNOW WE-
ARE AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE
TALKING A LOT NOT ONLY ABOUT
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC BUT
WE'RE ALSO TALKING A LOT ABOUT.
THE SYSTEMIC RACISM. IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY AND HOW THIS
COVERED NINETEEN IMPACT HAS HAD
A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS ISSUE OF OVER 90% OF
OIL DRILLING TAKING PLACE N.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THE NEXUS BETWEEN
COVER NECK THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. HOW IT SUPPOSES THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM THAT IT IN OUR
STATE. AND IN OUR COUNTRY AND
SO THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO EXPRESS. I'M SORRY
THAT THE CENTER FROM SAN DIEGO
THINKS THAT THIS MAY JUST BE A
PUBLIC PUBLICITY STUNT. YOU
KNOW I WOULD REMIND THE SENATOR
THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT YOUR
BILLS BUT THIS IS ABOUT A VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT IT.
FACING MANY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT. HOW WE LET SCIENCE
PREVAIL OVER POLITICS WE NEED
TO. B. LED BY SCIENCE AND NOT
BY POLITICS. INSIDE LIKE TO
CLOSE. AMPAS THAT. OUR
SCIENTISTS OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS ARE SAYING THAT WE NEED
A MINIMUM SET BACK AND- THAT
ONE KEY POINT IS AGAIN MY
RESPONSE TO THE MEDIA MAJORITY
LEADER THAT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. A BILL THAT REQUIRES A
SET BACK AND THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCING IN A PRESS RELEASE
THAT HE'S GOING TO CONSIDER SET
BACKS THE QUESTION BEFORE THIS
BODY TODAY ONE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THINKS IT
IS IMPORTANT. AS A POP CULTURE
PARM THAT'S YOUR. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADERS. JUST LAST YEAR
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN ISSUED
A RECOMMENDATION THAT LOS
ANGELES CA ON A NEEDS TO EXPAND
ITS MINIMUM SETBACK DISTANCES
BETWEEN SENSITIVE LAND USES AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OIL WELLS.
WE HAVE EVERY A STUDY THAT JUST
CAME OUT FROM THE UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH THEN
AGAIN. HIGHLIGHTS THE NEXUS
BETWEEN THE RESIDENTIAL
PROXIMITY TO OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT BIRTH OUTCOMES
PARTICULARLY RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS MORE. THIS IS MORE
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTS THIS
COMPELLING NEED FOR THE SET
BACK. YOU KNOW I- I REGRET.
THAT LABOR. IS OPPOSING THIS
BILL BECAUSE I CAN'T I THINK
IT'S A FALSE CHOICE. BETWEEN
JUSTICE AND HAVING GOOD UNION
JOBS. MANY OF THE STATEMENTS
MADE ABOUT THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LOST REVENUES THE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THAT ARE
THREATENED BY THIS BILL. IS TO
SUPPORT ANY FEAR MONGERING.
MANY OF THESE STATISTICS ARE
BASED ON THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THIS BILL THAT WAS CALLING
FOR A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOOT.
SETBACK THAT WAS. AGAIN IT IS
WHERE WE ARE REQUIRING. THE
DEPARTMENT TO ESTABLISH A
MINIMAL SET BACK BUT LEAVING IT
UP TO THE DEPARTMENT TO BALANCE
THE CONSIDERATION BETWEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT WE DO NOT HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PROTECTING
OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. AND HAVE A GOOD
JOBS. WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI-
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTIONDO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON AB THREE FORTY
FIVE I HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED AND AS AMENDED A TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ASK
THE CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. THE THREE
FORTY FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MORNING HI. JONES L. JONES NO
ALLEN ALL RIGHT NOW IN I
BURGESS NO BORDERS NO COVER
EURO. CABALLERO NO HERTZBERG
WALL NO WAY SO NO HUESO NO JACK.
JACKSON TURN GARDAI STERN HI.
THAT IS FOUR TO FIVE THE MOTION
FAILS. MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE MOTION. YES IT
WAS. THE CHAIR RECOGNIZES VICE
CHAIR JONES GOT JUST A POINT OF
ORDER ON THE RECONSIDERATION-
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THERE ARE
ONLY GOING TO ONE HEARING ON
NATURI SOURCES IS THAT CORRECT
OR- THANK YOU FOR RAISING THIS
ISSUE AT THIS TIME GIVEN WHERE
WE ARE ON OUR AGENDA TODAY.
DISSIPATED THAT WILL
CAMPAIGNING I. NEXT WEDNESDAY
AUGUST THE TWELFTH- THAT WAS
GONNA BE MY UPDATE SEGUEING TO
THE NEXT BILL SO OKAY BELIEVE
THERE WAS A DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR READ THE MOST WELL. YES
DELINO THANK YOU- SO AGAIN THE
RECORDED VOTE WAS. FOUR TO FIVE
SO THE MOTION FAILS
RECONSIDERATION HAS BEEN
REQUESTED THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME MEMBERS
JUST A TIME CHECK WE'RE AT. I'M
SORRY YES THANK YOU YOUR CALL
VOTE ON THE- RECONSIDERATION
PLEASE YEAH I HEARD SOME
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR AND I'M
NOT ABLE TO HEAR IT. BEHIND THE
WALL THAT'S FINE SO ON THE
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION MADE
BY SENATOR JACKSON WILL DO A
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS ON THE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER SESSION ONLY FOR
RECONSIDERATION. HI MONNING ALL
RIGHT JONES NO NO ALLEN HI
ALLEN ALL RIGHT FORGES NO NO
BORDERS NO COPYRIGHT. HERTZBERG.
HUESO NO HUESO NO JACKSON HI
JACKSON HI A STERN TONIGHT
STERN. THAT THAT HAS OF FOR
VOTES. THANK CHAIR RECOGNIZES
SENATOR HERTZBERG YES QUALITY
OF THE BETWEEN THE HOUSES I
DON'T SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BUT
I WOULD CERTAINLY PROVIDE THE%
PAYMENT OPTION THE RACIAL MAKES
THE RIGHT APPROACH THANK YOU
FOR ALL MY SECOND PARTY. WILL
THE FOR IF IT COMES AGAIN AT
OUR THE I THOUGHT WER ENACT
REP HIS CLUB THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO WHAT IS THE VOTE ON
RECONSIDERATION SO WITH RICH
BERG HI IT IS FIVE TWO THREE.
MOTION CARRIES RECONSIDERATION
IS GRANTED THANK YOU MEMBERS-
TIME CHECK WORD ABOUT ELEVEN
THIRTY IN A MOMENT I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CASH MEMBERS WHO DID
NOT VOTE ON THE EARLIER SENT
COUNT VOTE. AND WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO I AM NUMBER FOUR.
CONSULTANT LIFT THE CALLING
CALL THE ROLL ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM TO AB EIGHT
THREE EIGHT FILE ITEM THREE AB
TEN SEVENTY ONE FILE ITEM FIVE
AB IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE FOR
ITEM SEVEN A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WELL I. M. A. B. THE
TWENTY. NINE AM FILE ON NINE OF
FOUR A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR FILE ITEM SIXTEEN A. B. B.
TWO TWENTY SIX- ALLEN. ALLEN HI
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI THAT'S
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO CONCISE
CALENDAR YOU SAID OPTED. MATT
OTHER HELP KEEPING SOME OF YOU
MAYBE WEREN'T HERE ITEM SIX AB
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY COOPER
WAS DRAWN. SO THAT WILL NOT BE
ON TODAY'S DOCKET- AND WE ARE
SCHEDULED FOR A HARD STOP AT
TWELVE THIRTY FOUR IN THE
MIDDLE OF SOMEBODY'S TESTIMONY
OR- THE BILL WE GO A LITTLE BIT
OVER- BUT IT DOES APPEAR WE
WON'T MAKE IT THROUGH A- FULL
AGENDA TODAY. SO THE COMMITTEE
WILL RECONVENE ON WEDNESDAY
AUGUST THE TWELFTH WE DON'T YET
HAVE A TIME OR ROOM ASSIGNMENT
FOR THAT BUT- IT WILL BE A WEEK
FROM TODAY. WEDNESDAY OCT
TWELFTH WHERE WE WOKE UP. WITH
A LARGE WHEREVER WE LEAVE IT AT
ROUGHLY TWELVE. SCEPTER WITH
THAT THANK FOR VAST EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY WELCOME IS
MEMBER THE FLOORS YOURS THANK
YOU FOR MY MISTER MEMBERS OF
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
IN YOUR FOR WORKING WITH BMI
STUFF ON. THREE FOR THE RECORD
UP IN THE- FOR EIGHT NINE THREE
NINE WHICH IS ON THE PROVIDE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND SO TODAY
WE'RE ON AB TWENTY SIX WITH
CAGR THE SUBSTANCE TO
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS THAT
WORKS FINE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SURVATION THE GENERAL. THE
EASTERN TRANSFER FOR AGENTS
CALTRANS THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY THE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION AND THE STATE PARKS
RECREATION COMMITTING THE
COMMISSION SETTLING MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS THE SPEND NEARLY A
DECADE THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
PERMANENTLY PROJECTS THAT THE
STATE. BY WHAT IT AREA WERE
BROKEN IS FOR. WORKING WITH ME
THAT THE A OF MEANS IT ENDS
YEARS OF OVER BUT CLEAR ROAD ON
A LOCATION THAT'S BEEN DEEMED
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND LEGALLY AND
FEASIBLE AT A LOCAL LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. TO THE
OTHER. USABLE OPTIONS. THE BILL
ENJOYED. FROM BERMAN OR- SUCH
AS IN OUR DC AND THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND STATE LOCAL
STATE AND LOCAL BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. AND PARKS
THE PORTER SUCH AS THE STATE
PARK SHIN WHICH IS THE FAULT OF
THE SPELL. THE BILL HAS
PROVISIONS. I WOULD TO SAVE
IMPROPER TO ONE OF THE FIVE
MOST VISITED IN THE IN PER
SYSTEM FOR GENERATIONS TO COME
BE RESPECTFUL OF THE COMMITTEES
TIME I DON'T HAVE A PRINCIPAL
WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL OVER THE PHONE. ON
THE OTHER SUPPORT. MAY HAVE. I
RESPECTFULLY I HAVE A- THANK
YOU- MADAM AUTHOR WE'RE JUST
GOING TO CHECK IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE GALLERY HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. ANY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SING NONE
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE LINE ON THIS
BILL IN SUPPORT AB. FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ONLY IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX. CAN BE
JUST A FEW MOMENTS THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ONLY PRESS AT ONE
TIME OR YOU END UP PICKING
YOURSELF OUT OF THE- YOU.
DURING THE LINE NUMBERS. FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE. ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT OR ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT AM
PLEASE JUST A NAME. AND WHETHER
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE GO AHEAD HE
BAKER STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR
THE DISSOCIATES FROM THE
RESOURCES LEGACY FUND IN
SUPPORT. NINE NINE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WE COME UP WITH AN AUTO
WITH THE PROPER PUBLIC LAND IN
SUPPORT. SHOULD NINE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
STEPHANIE HE GETS QUITE WHAT
THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION
REGISTERING STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IN LINE TEN TWENTY
OR ONE THOUSAND TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE MINE. ONE
THOUSAND TWENTY OR TEN TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO ZERO.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO WENT UP
IN SEVENTY FOUR OR TEN SEVENTY
FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THREE PEOPLE ARE CHARGED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IN NINE EIGHT SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOWN SILVER ENDANGERED HABITATS
LEAGUE AND SAVE SANTA NO FREE
COALITION SUPPORT. NINE ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR OR ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING JAMIE
BELL ON BEHALF OF HUNDREDS OF
WILDLIFE AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF
THE PARK NOW COALITION
INCLUDING TREATY. ANTI REAL
VALLEY FATHERS AND FAMILIES AND
JOAQUIN. FOR HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET YOUR FOR ALL OUTDOOR OUT
REACHING YOU OUT OF LATINO.
FRESNO BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITY BROWN PROFESSOR THE
WORLD. GREEN AND FRESNO
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
OUT NOMINATION ALL REFUGEE
ADMINISTRATIVE COURT THANK YOU.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT
COMMENT. NINE SEVEN THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE MOMENT. SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BERMAN ZERO CALIFORNIANS FOR.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. Q. MODERATOR- ME
CHECK ONE MORE TIME. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW WE WILL MOVE TOP
POSITION ON AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX. NOT ON FILE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WHO IS TO. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE MOVING TO
ROOM. TWENTY ONE FORTY ANY ONE
IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE FORTY. HEARING NONE. WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINES DO
WE HAVE ANYONE CALLING IN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOR. TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS COMING
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON- SENATOR JONES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER CHURCHES TO A COUPLE
COMMENTS I THINK- AT FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX IT CREATES A-DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STREETS AND HIGHWAYS
CODE CODE ANDTHE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE. IT ALSO IS.
REALLY VALIDATES TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
WHICH THE CITY OF SAN CLEMENTE
AND A LARGE. THANK YOU
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION OF
CHALLENGE DO THAT TO THAT
DISCREPANCY. AND AUTHORIZE EXIT
EXPENDITURES AND DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES THAT THE CITY HAS
CHALLENGED. SO MAYBE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS THE AUTHOR COULD
DRESS IS WHITE THE PEOPLE NOT
DO FROM THE CAN. BE IN THE
HEARING LITIGATION THE WAY TO
GET. AND IN THIS SEEMS TO BE
TRYING TO IRRITATE THAT. ARE
COULD SIMPLE MANDATE APART TO.
TENSION FROM. AND THE BILL
PROTECT INVOICE AREAS WITH THE
STATE ALONE DE DOES REQUIRED
STRUCK OF SOME OTHER RESOURCES.
AND TO AND PROBABLY THE MOST
CONCERNING THING FOR ME IS.
WHAT IS THE BILL CODIFY AT
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AGENCY. TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY. JACK
WAS INTENDED TO MITIGATE IS NOT
GOING TO BE BUILT. SO IF YOU
ADDRESSES TWO ITEMS AND THEN
MAYBE SPECIFICALLY ON THE
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT WHO ARE THOSE
ENVIRONMENT WE ARE GOING TO BE
RECESSED. THOSE ARE CUTTING.
SOUTHWEST HI MY TO ASK OUR
THROUGH THE CHAIR I MAY UM AS
THE MOTOR CALL WAITING HELLO
ONE SECOND THREE THREE BYRD-
TORRES FROM THE CALIFORNIA FOR
PARKS FOUNDATION OF THE PERHAPS
ON ANSWER THEM A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL- ARBIL PART OF.
STATE PARKS CENTER THE STATE
BEACH AS NOT HOW.
TRANSPORTATION ROAD BEING ABLE
TO BE BUILT BUT WE'RE
PRESERVING THE PARK THAT'S WHAT
OUR BILL DOES SO IF I CAN. THE
BUTTON FAILED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS IN MORE DETAIL I
APPRECIATE THAT WOULD YOU SHARE
THE WITNESS'S NAME ONE MORE
TIME AND ISSUE AVAILABLE BY
TELEPHONE IS ON THE CARD IS ON
THE ON THE BALL. YOU SEE THERE
ARE TURISTS. PARKS FOUNDATION.
TIME IF YOU WOULD OF TRACY IF
YOU WOULD PRESS ONE AND ZERO
WILL BE ABLE TO OPEN YOUR LINE.
ONE MOMENT. AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
THE MODERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS- AND THANK YOU
CENTER CHEN FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEM I
WANT TO CLEAR THAT THE LANGUAGE
OF AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THE TO
ENSURING NO DEVELOPMENT OF ROAD
CONSTRUCTION. AND EVERYTHING
O'NEILL CONSERVANCY. ISSUE SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT. YOU
REFERENCED RELATED TO ON AN
ONGOING ROLE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION CORDER AGENCY
AND THEIR WORK AND LOOKING AT
TRAFFIC RELIEF IN SOUTHERN
ORANGE COUNTY. ARE NOT PART OF
THIS BILL THERE ARE OTHER
PIECES OF LEGISLATION- THEY MAY
BE AWARE OF THAT WILL LOOK BACK
AT THAT WHAT DOES. THAT. BACK
TO THE- D. THAT THE YOU
INDICATED DATE THE FUNNY DOES
NOT GO TO WORKING. THE FIRE
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE AS
FUNDING TO ENSURE. DETAIL WOULD
BE ADDITIONAL. ENVIRONMENTAL
LAND AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
YOU CAN SOUTHERN ORANGE COUNTY
IN NORTHERN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
FOR A ROAD THAT WOULD BE
CONTRACTED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AGENCY.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THAT FUNDING DOES NOT GO TO ANY
NONPROFIT FOR GOING TO GEN THAT
WOULD BE FUNNY. WE HAVE THE
PUBLIC IMAGE. AFTER THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC AND
HAVEN'T PROTECTION. THANK YOU-
ANYTHING FURTHER FROM THE
AUTHOR. NO I THINK THAT ACT
SUMMARIZES THE THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING A STATE PARK
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PROTECTING THE OUTDOOR
RECREATION THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
IN CONCLUSION I WOULD LIKE
URGENT I VOTE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM STE JACKSON
THIS IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX THANK.
PLEASE LARA. EIGHTY EIGHT
FOURTEEN SIX THE MOTION TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS MONEY. NINE
MONNING HI JONES. JONES NO
ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT BURGESS.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
HERTZBERG. HUESO. HUESO AYE
JACKSON JACKSON ALL RIGHT STERN
TONIGHT STERN ONLINE. SIX ONE
NO WILL PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL
A SIX ONE IT'S OUT WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF MISSING PERSON THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES CHAIR
RECOGNIZES VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JUST A QUICK POINT
OF ORDER ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL- I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE
ON THIS IN THE DEBATE ON UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL. BUT WE WOULD
HAVE GONE THROUGH CAN'T
TRANSPORTATION OF FOR MORE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS. ON ON SOME
OF THE ASSETS TO THE BILL SO I
JUST WANT TO BRING THAT TO
LIGHT AND- IT IF YOU DON'T SHOW
OF PASSAGE ON THE FLOOR. MAYBE
NEXT YEAR IT WOULD GO THROUGH
BOTH COMMITTEES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DULY NOTED. THANK YOU
MADAM AUTHOR- MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY ONE OH
SIX. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID ARE
CURRY. GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
MORNING SENATOR- THANKS TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. BEEN VERY LONG. A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHURCH
MEMBERS THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
A COMMITTEE STUFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY OFFICE ON THIS
MEASURE. I WILL BE TAKING ALL
THE GOOD MOMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS. AB
TWENTY ONE GENERATE FUNDING FOR
THE EXISTING THING BIRD IN
PROGRAM. THIS BILL WILL
ENCOURAGE FARMERS AND
LANDOWNERS TO CULTIVATE A PLAN
COVER CROPS OR NATURAL
VEGETATION ON IDLE LANDS TO
PROVIDE WATERFOWL AND UPLAND
GAME BIRDS WITH WILDLIFE
HABITAT. LACK OF A GLOBAL
NESTING COVER ESPECIALLY IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS LIKE THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY RICE GROWING
REGION IS A SIGNIFICANT
LIMITING FACTOR FOR BREEDING
WATERFALL AND OTHER BROWN
TESTING BIRDS. THE TESTING PER
PROGRAM IS ONE OF TO ME
CALIFORNIA GROWERS NEEDS AS
FUNDS CAN BE USED TO PLANT
COVER CROPS ENHANCE EXISTING
NESTING BIRD HABITAT. OR
ESTABLISHED NESTING COVER ON
LANDS THAT ARE FOLLOWED UNDER
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. THE TWENTY
ONE OH SIX IS A RESOURCE
GENERATING CONSERVATIONMEASURE
THAT WILL COMPLEMENT OUR
STATEWIDE GOALS OF KERR
SEQUESTRATION. IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY AND PROTECTION OF OUR
WATER FILL SPECIES. BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION ENJOYS
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FROM A
DIVERSE COALITION OF
SPORTSMEN'S GROUPS CONSERVATION.
AND PRIVATE LANDOWNER TO
REPRESENTATIVES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MARK
SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA. C.
ASIAN ADAM ROBINSON CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID OR
CURRY WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
GALLERY TO HEAR FROM MARK SMITH.
WITH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES TO
ALLOCATE HOWEVER YOU CHOOSE-
THE MICROPHONE SHARES MISTER
SMITH. CASTING MICROPHONE ON
YES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARK SMITH TESTIFYING
ONBEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION FIRST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR ALL OF THE WORK ANY
ATTENTION TO IMPROVE THE BILL-
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS SOME
BILLS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD THIS
MEANS COMMUNITY IS WELL INTO
ITS OWN POCKET TO HELP FUND AND
OVER STABBER. BUT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY SEVERAL YEARS AGO
RECOGNIZING THAT HABITAT IS A
LIMITING FACTOR IN THE
POPULATIONS OF THESE GROUND
NESTING BIRDS BOTH WATERFOWL
AND UPLAND BIRDS THIS PROGRAM
PUTS MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF
LAND OWNERS. TO OPERATE THIS.
THROUGH A VOLUNTARY PRACTICE TO
INCENTIVIZE THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN CREATING THIS NECESSARY
HABITAT FURTHER AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL ALSO NOW INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THE UPLAND GAME BIRD PROGRAM
SO THAT WE COMMUNITY THAT WAS
THIS PROGRAM SEE BETTER
OUTCOMES. GO WATER HOLE MEMBERS.
IT'S A SMALL SEGMENT OF THE
SPORTS COMMUNITY BUT IT IS THE
SEGMENT THAT HAUNTS FOR
WATERFOWL AND UPLAND BIRDS OVER
80% MEMBER SUPPORTED HIM THIS
INVESTMENT INTO THESE PROGRAMS
THIS THIRTY ONE TEAM TO MONEY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE I THINK WE KNOW THAT
THE DEPART UNDER WE DON'T NEED
TO WAIT THE REST. BASED BUDGET.
PROGRAM OUR LET US HELP TO
FUNDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER SMITH. NOW THE
SECOND WITNESS IN SUPPORT I
THINK IS IT ADAM ROBIN IS HE
HERE IN THE ALLERY OR IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. PARDON ON THE
PHONE- SO- MODERATOR CAN YOU
BRING IN ADAM RAHMAN- WITHIN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS IS LOUIS AND ACTUALLY
WE'VE HAD A SWITCH AND ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION- I WAS GOING TO WIN
FOR ADAM IS THE SECOND MESSAGE
THAT. THAT IS FINE IN SORRY
MAKES UP WE GOT THAT NOTED THEN
SOUNDED LIKE A WIN BACK SO HERE
YOU ARE THE PHONE LINE IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SIR. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE
ZERO SIX. HI AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE RICE COMMISSION- HAS
PARTNERED WITH. CONSERVATION
GROUPS WATERFALL ASSOCIATIONS
AND OTHERS AND HAVE MADE
CONSERVATION AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT YOU ARE PRIORITY- AND
IT CONTINUES TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR OUR- GROWERS CROP
SACRAMENTO VALLEY. WE'VE PROVED.
IT PROGRAM WORK. BOB PROVING AN
EXTRA UPON THE WETLAND. AND THE
VIBE OF THE FOR AB TWO ONE ZERO
SIX IS YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT IF
PROPERLY FUNDED. ONLY
ADDITIONAL SUCCESS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND IF YOU APPRECIATE GIVING US
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY
AND ASK YOUR RIGHT FOOT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER BROWN
WILL NOW GO TO THE- SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FIRST CHECKING IN THE
GALLERY YES WE HAVE SOMEBODY
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
NAME. MEDIATION AND YOUR
POSITION MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
IS ROY GRIFFITH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES YES IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE GERMAN ARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE EIGHTEEN KLEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
SPORTSMEN'S FOUNDATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK. THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY SING
NINE LET'S ROOM LOOK AT ROOM
MONEY FORTY. YES AND MEMBERS OF
THE MY NAME IS BILL GAINES AND
I'M REPRESENTING THE SYSTEM
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
THE CLERY BASIN WETLANDS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEAREST CREATION CALIFORNIA
STATE CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
WILD TURKEY. RATIONS CAL OR
WEAPONS IN A WATERFALL COUNCIL
AND THE BLACK FRANK GROUP ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE OH SIX. RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM. THIRTY SEEN
ON. GREATER IN THE PHONE LINE.
THOSE WENT TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME SECOND STREET
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
HELLO. IN NINE ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
OR ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ONE OF
THEM WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS. AND MINE ONE
THOUSAND TWENTY OR TEN OR
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND MINE ONE THOUSAND
TWENTY OR- TEN TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
MOVING ON TO LINE FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN FIVE SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YOU'RE THEN WE
HAVE THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
SUPPORT. NINE TWO FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WAKE UP WITH- PHYSICAL
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. IN NINE ONE NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND ONCE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA COURT
WHAT THE IN OUTDOOR SPORTS
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR THIS APARTMENT STRICTER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN LINE FOR
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MARIANN WARMER DAM ON BEHALF
OF WORLD COUNTY SUPPORTED THE
MEASURE. NINE ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX OR ELEVEN
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MISTER
JERRY BROWN THIS IS MARK ANTONY
WITH CALIFORNIA ARTS USING
DELTA WATERFOWL FOUNDATION. AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. AND NINE
FIVE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DANIEL CONNOLLY I WAS THE STATE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR PHEASANTS
FOREVER AND QUAIL FOREVER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE
OH SIX. AND MINE ONE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN OR
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT MORE.
MEMBERS ADAM BOBBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IF TRUMP SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT. IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANY. OPPOSITION
LOOKING TO THE GALLERY FIRST DO
WE HAVE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WILL
ROOM MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE. RESIDENTS IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR TO CHECK PHONE LINES
THIS WOULD BE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY ONE OH
SIX. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. SECOND YOU SHOULD
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THEN IT
FIRST COMES FROM THE LINE FOR
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE THIS TIME
MAN- THE CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CA ARE PRETTY EIGHT
OF CHAPTER I DON'T REMEMBER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
DIDN'T GET IT AND WITH THE
CUBAN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. MADAME MODERATOR. YES
THANK YOU MR AND- MISTER BANKS
GOES MINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
MIND OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
I'M SORRY I WAS TRYING TO GET
IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. CAN
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MISTER
VASQUEZ IF YOU COULD GO AHEAD
AND IF I YOURSELF AGAIN. SIR
KEVIN I'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. WE ALSO HAVE A
LINE LINE ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT OR
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEARLY PRODUCTION AND WE
ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION BUT WE
ARE NEUTRAL FOR VARIOUS REASONS
WE APPRECIATE THE LOVE- BONSER
TO PUSH THIS BILL. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN Q. THANK YOU I MIGHT HAVE
MOVED TOO QUICKLY EARLIER CAN
WE JUST CHECK ONE MORE TIME
MADAME MODERATOR. ABSOLUTELY IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN.
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
BEGIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL- EVENT
VERY LIGHTLY DIALOGUE WITH THEM
AND- I THINK THAT I MEAN THE
POINT WHERE MOST OF MY TERMS
AND QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN AT.
LEAST TODAY. YOU IS THAT A XIN.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MORE FROM
SENATOR JONES ANYONE ELSE WISH
TO SPEAK ON THIS. SEEING NONE
THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILERA CURRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SURE I
JUST WANNA REMIND EVERYONE THIS
GENERATES FUNDING FOR EXISTING
NESTING BIRD HABITAT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. AND AS A CHILD I
REMEMBER THERE'S ALWAYS
PHEASANT SURROUNDING QUAYLE IN
THIS TIMES GOING ON I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE WEREN'T
ANY AND I FOUND OUT WE NEED. TO
CAPITA. SO THAT'S THE PREMISE
FOR THE BILL SO. AND I
SUCCESSFULLY RIVAL THANK YOU-
TO THE CONSULTANT WE HAVE A
MOTION TO DO PASS AS AMENDED AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE THE MOTION IS- AB ON AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MONEY BY MONEY-
A JONES JONES HI ALLEN. ALL
RIGHT OR DO. BURGESS I YOU'RE A
CAN BE I HEARD. HUESO HUESO ALL
RIGHT JACKSON. JACKSON ALL
RIGHTS STERN. STERN ALL RIGHT
THAT IS. EIGHT ZERO. THAT EIGHT
ZERO THAT'S ENOUGH FOR THE BILL
TO MOVE THAT WILL PLACE IT ON
CALL FOR MISSING MEMBERS THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGIR CURRY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS.
SOME JUST TO KNOW TIME ORGAN
MOVE TO ITEM. THAT'S AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED. THAT WILL BE
PRESENTED TODAY BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KIRK BY CORK BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED AT THE CONCLUSION
OF THIS WE WILL LIFT CALLS SO I
WOULD MEMBERS WHO AREN'T ON THE
FLOOR TO PLEASE FACT FLOOR.
WILL BE. WRAPPING UP AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS BILL- TODAY
AND WE WILL MOVE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TO THE
HEARING SCHEDULED FOR NEXT
WEDNESDAY AUGUST THE TWELFTH-
IN WILL PROVIDE SOME FURTHER
INSTRUCTION BEFORE WE WRAP UP-
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
WE'RE DOING THIS TO PROTECT SO
YOU CAN HAVE. THE FULL BENEFIT
OF THE HEARING OKAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COOPERATION- THANK YOU
SEN CABALLERO FOR YOUR PATIENCE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I'M SORRY
YES I'M SORRY VICE ARE REAL
QUICK POINT OF ORDER AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE- REGARDING THE TIMING
OF THE- THE SHORTENED TIME
FRAME WE HAVE IN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND THE NUMBER OF
BILLS ARE GOING TO BE HEAD OVER.
THE NEXT I WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS
CAN TO ANALYZE AGAIN AB THIRTY
THIRTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND SEE IF IT AT AND ACTUALLY
ANALYZE IF IT COMPLIES WITH THE
IMPORTANCE OF. LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN AND
MAYBE WE HOPE BY ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO PULL THAT BILL. AND
REDUCE REINTRODUCE IT NEXT YEAR
THANK YOU DULY NOTED THANK YOU.
SENATOR COMING YEAR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. AND I
AM PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT MR
CORK WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS NOTED
ON PAGES FIVE AND SIX SIX OF
THE ANALYSIS. AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED REMOVED A SUNSET
PROVISION TO ENSURE THAT STATE
AGENCIES WILL CONTINUE TO
ACCOUNT. FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
PLANNING BUILDING AND INVESTING
IN STATE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
ORIGINAL. AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED CREATED THE CLIMATE
SAFE INFRASTRUCTURE WORKING
GROUP. COMPOSED OF SCIENTISTS
ENGINEERS AND ARCHITECTS TO
EXAMINE HOW TO BEST INTEGRATE
CLIMATE INFORMATION WITH THE
STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGN.
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION.
THE WORKING GROUP SUBMITTED ITS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LAYING OUT A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MAKE THE
STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
RESILIENCE RESILIENT. AND
SUSTAINABLE IN ORDER TO
WITHSTAND A WIND RATE WIDE
RANGE OF CLIMATE IMPACTS
HOWEVER THEIR WORK IS FAR FROM
OVER AND IS WHY THE SUNSET DATE
NEEDS TO BE REMOVED. AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED MAKE THE WORKING
GROUP PERMANENT AND THEY CAN
MANY AMENDMENTS WILL UPDATE THE
ROLE OF THE WORKING GROUP. TO
COORDINATE ON OTHER STATE LEVEL
PLANNING EFFORTS RELATED TO
CLIMATE RESULT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. ON THE PHONE TO
A TO TEST I INTO THIS MEASURE
IS ARE BOTH FROM THE UNION
CENTER CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND I AM
INFORMED THAT WE DO HAVE- JASON
BARBOSA. UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS ON A CO HOST PHONE
LINE I'LL MOVE TO THE
MODERATOR. AND ASK IF YOU CAN
BRING OUR WITNESS ST IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN MEMBERS THIS
IS JASON VARGAS WITH THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS OR THAT
SPONSORED THIS BILL. AND ADD
SENATOR CAFIERO EXPLAINED THIS
LEGISLATION MAINTAINED A
WORKING GROUP. AS WELL AS THE
PROVISION IN A LOT OF REQUIRE
STATE AGENCIES TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE CURRENT. AND FUTURE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN PLANNING
DESIGNING BUILDING OPERATING
MAINTAINING AND INVESTING IN
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
WITHOUT THIS BILL- THOSE THAT
REQUIREMENT AND THE WORKING
PEOPLE SUNSET AFTER THIS YEAR.
IT HAS BEEN WELL KNOWS THE
INTERRELATION CLIMATE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. WE ARE FACING A NEW
NORMAL I'VE EVER INCREASING
VARIABILITY IN EXTREMES IN
CLIMATE CONDITIONS AND IS
EXPECTED TO WORSEN OVER TIME.
AND AS WE'VE SEEN MANY TIMES IN
RECENT MEMORY EXTREME WEATHER
AND OTHER IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HAVE A BIG IMPACT. ON
CALIFORNIA'S AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR ROADS OUR
ELECTRICITY GRID OUR
RESERVOIRS. AMONG OTHERS AND OF
COURSE INFRASTRUCTURE PLAYED A
CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR LIVES AND
OUR LIVELIHOOD. AND THERE'S A
NEED TO SPEND PUBLIC FUNDS
WISELY SO PROJECT CAN CONTINUE
TO STRONG DESIGN FOR MANY
DECADES DESPITE CHANGING
CLIMATIC CONDITIONS. AB TWENTY
WILL HELP TAKE IT TO REFINE
APPROACH TO BUILDING AND
MAINTAINING INTEREST IT WAS
STANDING IN REQUIRE CHANGE. I
HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- THIS
WOULD BE WILL CHECK FIRST IN
OUR GALLERY ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED.
THIS WILL BE NAME
IDENTIFICATION AND AFFILIATION
ONLY LETS SLIP TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO SEE IF ANYONE WISHES
TO TESTIFY THEY'RE- SEEING NONE
WILL MOVE TO THE MODERATOR AND
THE TELEPHONE LINES TO SEE IF
ANYONE'S IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED. THANK YOU MISTER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
MOMENT WHEN WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS. IN OUR FIRST COMMENT
COME FROM LINE ONE THOUSAND
FIFTY ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
OR ELEVEN FIFTY SIX. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
THANK YOU ONE OF THEM WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE BOTTOM LINE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. N. NINE
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN. OR A ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
NINETEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CIVIL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR. LET
ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION. IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE. MOVING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANY OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED SEEN
NONE MOVE TO A MADAME MODERATOR
AND THE TELEPHONE LINES ANYBODY
IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB. TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED. THANK
YOU MISTER CARE IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR. WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- FLOOR DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE
DO I HEAR A MOTION IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED. I
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
HUESO- THIS IS A TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR COMING YEAR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK WILL MOVE
TO THE CONSULTANT TO CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MINING. BY MONEY HI JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN. ALLEN ALRIGHT
GORGEOUS. BORJA SNOW COVER EURO
THE BUREAU HIGH HERTZBERG.
HUESO HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON
ALL RIGHT STERN. STERN ON A-
SIX TWO. SIX TO THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD- I THINK WE'LL PLACE
THAT ON CALL IS WELL THAT
MEMBERS WE ARE AT THE POINT
WHERE PLEASE ANY MEMBER OF
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
PLEASE REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA BE LIFTING CALLS IN
JUST A MINUTE. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DID PASS. AND SO WE'LL
MOVE BILLS THAT DIDN'T HAVE- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYBODY TO
VOTE IN MEMBERS REMINDER INTO
THOSE LISTENING IN THE PUBLIC.
WE WILL PICK UP. WITH FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE
AT OUR NEXT HEARING SCHEDULED
FOR A WEEK FROM TODAY WEDNESDAY
AUGUST THE TWELFTH. FURTHER DE
CAN'T DETAILS FORTHCOMING. IN
THE BILL'S FOLLOWING THAT TO
THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY HAVE LINED
UP ON THOSE THOSE PLANS WHEN.
COLLEGE I THIS HEARING. DOES
ALREADY TO GET PREPARE FOR A
LABOR COMMITTEE HEARING THAT IS
YOU KNOW WE HAD HELD UP- SO WE
ARE. CURTAILING THE AGENDA
TODAY TO BE PICKED UP A WEEK
FROM TODAY. I WANT TO THANK THE
MODERATOR WHO HELPED US WITH
THE PHONES I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE STAFF WHO. HELPED MAKE THIS
RUN SMOOTHLY AND FOR ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS FROM THE PUBLIC
WHO WERE ABLE TO JOIN US AGAIN
A REMINDER THAT IF YOU SOUGHT
TO BE HEARD AND WEREN'T ABLE TO
GET THROUGH YOU CAN'T SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENT. THE MEDIAN TO
READ THIS AND WATER AND THAT
WILL BECOME PART OF THE
RECOGNIZED RECORD- RELATED TO
THE BILLS THAT WERE HEARD
TODAY- AND- I GUESS THE
SERGEANTS TO PLEASE. CHECK TO
ANY MISSING MEMBERS- I THINK
WE'RE GOOD TO GO I KNOW VICE
CHAIR JONES SAID HEWILL NOT BE
BACK- SO WE'RE GOING ON S. THE
CONSULTANT TO LIFT THE CALL
WILL GO THROUGH THE BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL AND THEN WE WILL
WRAP UP. OKAY FILE ITEM FOR AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ONE BORJAS.
HERTZBERG. IS FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX YES HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
THAT'S SEVEN ONE. THE BILL IS
SEVEN ONE THE BILL IS OUT. NEXT
WE HAVE FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWENTY ONE ZERO SIX THE CURRENT
VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT THAT'S NINE
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT NINE
ZERO FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED THE CURRENT VOTE
IS ONE. SIX TWO HERTZBERG ALL
HERTZBERG HI SEVEN TWO. THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO THAT IS
IT AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED SO
WERE THROUGH THE ROOF THE ROLE
FOR TODAY- I WANT TO THANK
MEMBERS FOR YOUR COOPERATION
AGAIN COMMITTEE STAFF SENATE
STAFF TECHNICAL STAFF WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR HELP
FULL FACILITATION. WE WILL.
STANDIN ADJOURNMENT BUT- THE
COMMITTEE WILL NOTICE THE
FOLLOW UP HEARING FOR NEXT
WEDNESDAY AUGUST THE TWELFTH OR
WE WILL PICK UP ON THIS AGENDA
TODAY'S SESSION IS ADJOURNED